[Music]
we're rolling
this is already the most chaotic episode
we i've ever done of the show don't
blame that on me
well
i i will i can and i will and i have and
i said what i said okay okay because
there there is a there is an
effervescent energy and today's the day
our careers end it feels like i blame it
on your unicorn everything you're
already drinking
canned wine you served this to me i
didn't it was just it was this is what i
drink in the car uh when i have to visit
my mom in a nursing home and i just have
that on standby that's not something
that guests should be drinking bitch are
you curling your fucking shit
i'm curling my hair you should look into
it you know what's crazy is i honestly i
have a bag of shit in my car
and i was gonna i was like kind of
running
somewhat late and this bitch is 45
minutes late like she's the aretha
franklin of comedy
and i was like i'll just get ready on
air no that'll be rude and you're using
a curly like the first curling iron ever
fucking made
that shit is crusty as shit it looks
like literally it looks like someone
found it in the ocean
oh god this i bought at a store called
delta variant
it's a new hair shop that opened uh in
the mall
so this is
don't like do everyone's curling iron
does not look like this
bitch
that thing looks like a bone it looks
like a fossil it's like i feel like i'm
in the the creation room of jurassic
park where they put the amber
this shit looks like bernie sanders
shower drain i mean it is very
very
dusty it's offensive and the fact that
you keep putting it in your face i'm
curling my hair uh because i don't want
to be half curled and i'm trying to look
good for your episode because you always
every time i see you you show up all
fucking benjamin button looking like a
snack are you gonna curl everything i
know now i do i can't just curl one i
gotta curl all of it do you want to use
a curling iron or you just do not
because i feel rejecting you feel
threatened
let's just address this female comics
feel threatened by each other and look i
honestly i will say i will go on record
i look really cute hold on you look so
cute why do you think i'm curling my
hair
you walked in with your fucking bb top
and your little abercrombie mini jeans
thank you like looking like okay were
you doing squats at your dad's funeral
speaking of dad dying are you coming for
everyone's dad i didn't realize that
crying burned so many calories and gave
you abs like that do you know why i
didn't have a dead dad body like that i
honestly it's funny you say that i did
ryan stickler's podcast and i put effort
in like to look cute
and what does that mean well like i
didn't wear a hoodie
okay i wear hoodies to everything fair
enough yeah yeah and it's i think it
might have just been a grieving thing
right didn't it i just didn't give a
fuck well here's the thing when you're
when your parents die you don't feel
sexy you don't by the way this is one of
my favorite things what did you wear to
the funeral
um and did you put on makeup okay so i
am a big component of a proponent of not
doing what everyone does not for a
wedding dress to the funeral i wore a
1980s uh
prom dress
i wore ass i wore front facing assless
chaps
and a tiara
my dad wrote in you just i was worried
he wasn't totally dead you know i don't
want to get buried alive i just wanted
to make sure he had a one last heart
attack just in case
i why do we have to dress like such
assholes at a funeral i i mean i get
that it's all about the one who died and
we're black and let's focus but
what person has lived that depressing of
a life
that's gonna want that depressing of a
funeral yeah yeah i think it's probably
i we should look into what the origin of
this is but my guess is because people
wild so hard when they're left with
their own devices someone had to put a
rule in someone had to put you're right
the fact that there's a rule don't wear
white to a wedding the fact that there
even has to be a rule says so much about
our nature like i'm going to this
bitch's wedding i'm going to wear a big
white dress like you can't the fact that
that had to be
instant yeah instituted as like a
cultural moray
is wild yeah i don't i think you just
called me a racial slur but i'm going to
keep rolling as i did and i just want to
prove how uncancible i really am okay uh
i number one cause the delta variant
thing is it's really awesome i i
understand that this is upsetting to
people that is pure botulism it looks
like ground zero for botulism is that
rust it's got athlete's foot
[Music]
it's got impetigo and i need you to stop
right that is um that brings us right
into our next sponsor
first of all you are kink shaming and i
don't appreciate it and you know
something more if i talk about it i have
a good one here i have a clean one here
that has no hair on it
wow because i know i like this one makes
me more comfortable because i'm like i
know i can't ruin it because it's ruined
and this one if i use it i'll ruin it
you won't ruin it yes it will the one
that you're using looks like it's
literally casting voodoo into your soul
with each curl don't point that shit at
me bitch don't point that shit at me
by the way here's what i'll say
i
this is my only disgusting makeup habit
or okay
i saw you walk the halls
i saw you walk the halls earlier
so here's what i'll say
everyone i'm obsessed with women's um
weird stuff they do when they get ready
like emily we were in the car
and uh we were into austin texas
god bless um look like the week before
you were there you're getting full
you're like getting ready i'm getting
doing it i'm just i'm doing an
impression of emily okay so even though
i probably should apply something you
look amazing okay thank you um
appreciate it we look really fresh thank
you appreciate that it's not delighting
it's baby we always women always do this
we get a compliment and we validate well
it's just the angle bitch you're
beautiful
in the in the dark
in the light thank you if i'm blind like
that bitch from the lionel richie video
and i feel like holding that
i went back and watched that video
recently it does not hold up should we
title this episode add she's a
dude she's in college she is in that yes
she's like in college like with her but
not that it's not legal but it's just so
wild to see this girl like in college
and he's like following her around the
camera it's a little creepy because now
that those are crimes yeah it's a little
wild i'm like if you're a comedian we
would we would never see you again but
your law order
episode if you're a comedian we never
see you again but thank you for the
spots
thank you the women are thanking you so
the way emily puts on eyeshadow is she
does she licks her brush first
emily she does this what kind of witches
are in this place
it's psychotic emily first of all i only
do it for the eyeliner not the blush
like that she had a bro blush from high
school
and she acted like licking the eyeliner
was any better
look i'm just telling you i feel like i
feel like you guys got snatched up from
the hills of west virginia all i know
well yeah that's my that's my background
so you know i wasn't snatched up i did i
didn't allow them they didn't want to
take me
they they wanted me to stay where i
belong this is like the ozarks on meth
this entire operation
i know
it is i'm having a yard sale would you
like to purchase oh wait we have san
pellegrino
illuminator do you need some uh mascara
give it to me like that miranda cosgrove
you can have it oh thank you um uh have
you used it pink eye is my favorite
eyeline
you guys are keeping the lips and
putting this right in my bag it's heavy
it feels like this is an eyeliner choice
that was made on edibles it's like a
a green it's like a um divorcee green
okay i need to see your makeup tutorial
uh of what you've purchased on edibles
how many times has emily licked this one
she just deep throated it a couple of
times just for uh my own amusement i
often make her that's a pretty color
though it wasn't good i have a hard time
with green i also have gray eyeliner i
think i was in mourning when i bought
that yeah see when you're in mourning
you just
thank you for reminding me your outfits
are terrible excuse me yes no
no not you
not you are you saying my gas station
horse shirts are terrible actually i
have a gas station fleece horse jacket
where
how much i'll buy it right now i'm
joking bitch oh my god i was in south
carolina with a very toxic man who i had
to get a restraining order with on
valentine's day love is real no it's not
when was that
uh 2017. okay that's before i knew you
yes is he single now just for probably
uh attacking the next woman because you
know it's a cyclical process yeah
borderline personality disorder so fun
um i've i walked into a gas station and
i was emotionally in emotional duress
and i just saw this horse jacket it was
like a beacon of hope you know i just i
just saw this like fleece jacket hanging
up right because you could make a noose
out of it i could just
suffocate yourself in it could you make
a new set of fleece
more kate spade made a noose out of a
scarf
i mean like a scarf wow like a pashmina
that is a cozy death it is wow that's a
good title for your membership
we're allowed to do this we have dead
parents we do we are allowed to joke
about macabre things yes
macabre macabre but i like mccoy you're
gonna correct me well macabre is like in
a mustard yellow
okay you're in a doo-doo brown
fucking fake turtleneck the one time the
one bitch i don't want to hear it one
time we both like condiments
as soon as i look on the way out you
look like it on the way in this is a
before and after
i don't know what is i was like you came
in i was wearing like a cute hoodie you
come in i wanted to bring sunshine all
iggy azalea
and you've got so many tan lines i can't
help what's happening you have a
melanoma the melanoma matches it's
getting dark
your boobs are bigger than i've ever
seen them i've i told you i put on
grease grief weight yeah and it went in
my tits and my ass they are a little in
my labia my majoras really yeah a little
little meaty down there meaty paws is
that the
not at coachella this so
um
are people
still people yes that's the craziest
part about this is actually yes so two
women that don't hate each other a snort
came out that just undid the big tits
that canceled them out i'm so sorry you
guys i'm obsessed with jesse because you
are one of the few people when i first
met you i would didn't i didn't i was
weirded out why i saw you on the corner
at the laugh actually
i saw you in the corner
doing business i feel like we should
let's before we get like deep into this
podcast which is going to be seven days
long
um we should preface with saying i have
literally seen you twice in a year so
this is why it sounds like
literal verbal diary like two puppies
that get to play for the first time i
know continue yeah you're also drinking
mushrooms in your coffee we're also rude
accurate
very accurate but i'm a silence breaker
also we are drinking these canned drinks
that have a a smattering a little
smidgen of thc adam devine turned me
onto these and they say hi boy yeah a
comedian gave it to me so let's
it's probably gonna make me go night
night oh fun ghoul i didn't i think i
did it wrong i did it wrong god damn it
i totally i always get this wrong i did
it the wrong way hey okay so you truly
uh call betty ford she opened that so
that's like a guy if this is an olympic
sport i get killed bitch that's like if
a guy uses his hand to take off your
bottom one second does it you're like
whoa
whoa i don't like how fast you did that
is it good yeah it's good i don't take
you can't waste time when it gets to
weed you just gotta grab it
wow that's delicious it really is really
good yeah it's kind of um
divine lavender
it's lavendery it's really really really
really good so we're looking at each
other i first would just like to defend
um the fact that i am currently wearing
uh a wetsuit that is strangling me with
the arms cut off you came in all cute i
was like i'm people are in they're ready
for if you're gonna be cute i'm gonna go
be cute you're you're cute and i pulled
out this um
in a panic yeah it's like you know when
you have your period right there you
just pulled out i think i feel like
there's a hair yeah the other side no
there's just pulled out in here okay
what is it i don't know a couple bucks
there's so many animals in here on your
property you have really great boobs
thank you i know you talk about how
they're fake and everything but they're
great they really are they're good fakes
yeah if you see me do push-ups it gets
upsetting but
you don't want to see me do a verse
cowgirl but thank you how do you know
it's friday
sometimes they pucker on the side oh god
bless yeah it's been a hot minute yeah
you were making a point and i feel like
i cut you off no i just want to know the
first time oh the color of my bra yeah
if you're going to shame me oh it's
simpler
it's the worst color the audacity to
come in here and shame me and then show
up in that cross your heart bra what is
that what is this that is for a second
marriage
that is for a that is very dress that
you got at white house black market for
your second wedding someone loved me
twice i'll take it in tampa
i usually don't wear bras i don't even
want to wear them i don't either should
we just take them off yeah but mine is
oh yeah mine doesn't clip in the van i'm
sweating i'm i'm going to take mine off
i honestly put it on ruefully
because like ah
fucking out did you step on my back damn
it i just got tetanus this bitch ripped
my papers off
very cute pictures you know the way you
have to take a broth like this like in a
car
like look at that
yeah that's not yeah we're not wearing
bras no fuck it by the way it looks so
much cuter can i tell you does it you
your boobs are so perky
that why would you put a bra on them i
don't know because society tells me i
can't have my natural tits out what are
you talking about this looks sick does
it yes it's like two um alligator eyes
populating
um
i would have to
call my doctor who
does all the remote control
uh work to get me to ovulate wait a
minute is this
whitney or is this the
is this the ai i would have to call a
couple of russian gentlemen to know if
i'm on ovulating or not
um
elon musk can you let me know who knows
wait i don't know i don't have like an
app of when i'm ovulating like i don't
know i do i need to know are you i i
don't know
what's the app
it's a can i say the app period tracker
yes what do you mean
you can put all your moods in you can
you can let you know it keeps track of
when you're being bitchy and cranky
let's see if i'm ovulating okay
i think i am because explain this to me
so you it's like a journal for your it's
a journal for your for your blood vagina
it's a blood journal it's a blood
journal in the beginning when you have
your period like towards the beginning
does it like look like um
uh hershey's syrup
close it's more like a one steak sauce
oh and then i wanna right bye yeah yeah
i'm a week away from ovulating okay so
this is just pure excitement to see you
but so how many days do you ovulate is
everyone obviously the same amount of
time i feel like i've been ovulating
since i started my period but i don't
know if that's science um i feel like i
just ovulate a lot and so when you're
ovulating uh you
do use birth control
are you like my dad my dad was a
gambling man
of his death my dad is dead and he was a
gambler so i don't use anything let's
not to keep his honor alive so why do
you need to know your like what purpose
does it serve you emotionally like oh no
wonder i'm so yes nervous oh right yeah
and to keep if a near fuck boy to keep
him away from my
my my cookie i
i have so many i don't even know what so
wait can we get back to
when you first saw me
i know where you felt when i first saw
you i was very um
kind of evasive and confused like
because here's why a lot of people when
they see wild animals they get scared
and like they want to move away or like
bugs people i was with someone last
night that was like there was a
grasshopper and
it was like i had to get out you know
when grasshoppers are hard and they hit
the window and he was like i'm going to
puke some my only thing this isn't good
yet
just
here's okay you know me my brand is
thank me later okay we'll get to it okay
we need that on a business card here's
what it is it's super it's super um it's
super insulting until it's not okay so
it's just on you i feel at home yeah i'm
just on you it feels like christmas to
um backtrack all your therapy okay undo
it right and see through it all and go
back to being in love with people that
are mean to you got it just for 30
seconds till i get to the compliment got
it so i see you and you're on the corner
and you're laughing
and you're like playing twister with
nobody
and you're talking to comics and you're
you've got like an airbrushed shirt on
that has like cherries on it
you've got nails that are bright your
your hair is all healthy it's all your
hair
like you're out here it's an avatar
i was doing twister with nobody you were
out there no i just mean you were like
having such a good time but i left the
lap factory and i was i i just was like
i don't th
at the time i wasn't able to vibrate on
that frequency like i just i didn't
understand
what that was
i don't know what it is grow up in
alcoholic home i assume that if someone
is like super energetic and happy there
must be something wrong with that person
i truly think that i'm like oh this
person's too happy with scientology like
i just feel like it just
it's fucking fishy because i actually
have a pamphlet
please i would love to i mean trust me
can i borrow some money so i can afford
it what is it
okay bit just turn real what is that
it's a card is a prescription no it's
this is like the weirdest bag this is
the most morning after pill shit i've
ever seen this is just a white bag
either that you would throw up in on an
airplane oh no it's got a card in it
yeah what is it oh it's a card i just
recently who's it for and my manager i
just fired
how'd that go i went great we love each
other card with an owl on it yeah
because when my mom was on her death bed
she said it looked like a tree owl and i
thought i could write a nice personal
story to him about it the one you fired
yeah yeah don't send this card okay but
yeah we're not doing it we're gonna keep
it we're not doing that right you can
keep it um i
yeah no it's so you're just like
confused
oh we're not you you're back but look
how nice you are you're sending a thank
you card to someone you fired yeah
because i wanted to like put some words
to the experience you know we were
together for a really long time and but
they got money they they did i mean you
know
but still it's a relationship i totally
know it can be difficult yeah yeah do
that especially as a woman mm-hmm can i
vent please like it and i usually don't
like to drag anyone through the mud and
i i look at people and i know people are
going through their own struggles
everyone's in pain all the time that's
fine but if you're an adult you don't
get to blame uh your behavior on
something that happened 40 years ago
that exactly and
and i hate to and i have never really
leaned on being a woman in this business
is so difficult
because i like you thrive in chaos and i
love challenges and i figure it the fuck
out and until lately we this is the
other thing i kind of dawned on me the
other day i was like
i haven't been a woman in this business
that long
right i was a kid oh my god i wasn't a
woman yet right i was a
girl in this business i feel like i just
became a woman right before i i drove to
this place
that is a it's a zoo it's a zoo you're
like matt damon we bought a zoo
i kind of new that i've developed out of
quarantine and i'm going with you know
what i it's kobe damage i have it too
we're all like
we all sound like michelin like old
michelin tires oh my god
this is not i mean it's probably because
i was vaping and honestly this was like
two years ago i could not get uh
over a speed bump without taking a knee
i was like this is i'm in shape i just
can't
take long breaths like i was like like i
couldn't get enough oxygen yeah because
vaping is so bad i know so are we not
vaping at all anymore no you're smoking
bud just smoke bud just smoke flour okay
in the morning with your morning
mushrooms that i do i sprinkle it right
in there okay we're gonna vent so the
venting is and i'm not gonna say any
names but if you google you can find
them um
jeffy seinfeld
damn it
no i'm never going to get to be on that
show
uh i've i just expressed what i needed
from people that i work with and
um
you know
everything that's happened in my life
you know like you said we joke about it
but i have lost my parents in a very
short amount of time yeah are you making
me tequila i am i'm pouring tequila in
thank you in case you start crying and
stealing the thunder we got to make sure
these tears don't come out
bitch i put lashes on i'm not wasting
heavy do you know i'm not wasting the
glue that it took to put these on i put
these on for you do you know i'm
obsessed and that guy in the corner who
looks like he might be in a very
tumultuous marriage
he's in a very tumultuous relationship
with me i'm the bad marriage
in his life he's got a wonderful home
life a traumatic work life nailed it but
no do you know how to cry lying down if
you're ever going to cry on your makeup
you just always slide down yeah yeah
just lie down that's literally genius
because i was doing i was working out
this morning and i was crying into my
nose no no no no you got to slide out
and if you need to do weights or
something for whatever you need to do
you can still multitask but you got to
just lie back so whenever i'm going to
like a hollywood event where i know i'm
gonna get anxious and trigger or
something bad's gonna happen i'll just
lie i'll just sit in the back seat so as
soon as something weird happens i can
just lie down that's genius lie down cry
get it out it's like taking a piss and
then you
you man the fuck up and you walk in
there pro tip mm-hmm by whit yeah you
pull your spanx up and you go
pretend that you want to be on a cw show
you're pouring the tequila with pro tips
you need to make this a segment of the
show where you're just pouring tequila
anyway tell me about your deadpool and
if you're gonna gag on that dick you
better make sure he's on top so you can
cry lying down get a little powdered nad
so you stay young forever death becomes
her not me bitch you're not getting me
i snort david sinclair
that guy's a thousand he he's a wizard
but he is incredibly he looks like
really walks the walk he looks like he
still should be breastfeeding and i
don't trust it he's one that gets
wizardry he's one of the first
uh
doctors or healers or experts that i
uh have seen that i respect based on
their uh
advice being congruent with their
appearance like right you know when you
go to a dentist they have like horrible
teeth
like why do you have stonehenge what's
going on got to go joe dirt i've got to
go
or when you go to dinner i need to leave
uh when you go to a therapist that is
like crazier than you you're like you
know what this isn't working i had this
one therapist one that i went to because
i i go to one and she she's so hardcore
she was like i don't want to see you
anymore for a while like you need to go
see somebody else or because i'm not
gonna let you re-embed your trauma by
talking about the same thing over and
over again you need to take a break from
me like i was i was starting to be late
i was like i would come in and talk
about the same guy over and over again
he's like she's like you can't talk
about this guy for 30 days you need to
uh try to do no apologizing for 30 days
because you come in here and all you do
is apologize
and it's a drain and it's exhaust so i
had a
like a rubber band or uh what is it a
scrunchie that's like a band called cock
ring
what's it called i mean now i'm horny i
don't know what it's called but i'm
hungry and i'm horny
that's a cock band it's you know what i
mean like a like a hair band yeah like a
hairband normal hair so i had it in
everything like a look at why can't i
think of the thing it's called mouse
hairstyle i hear a tie that's all it is
that was so old
it was the oldest thing we've ever done
um and uh
i had to do 30 days no apologizing
mostly because when you're apologizing a
lot of times you're just trying to get
sympathy or victimizing yourself or
trying to make yourself small and the
other person doesn't want you to be
small or it's clearly an old tic that
you're programmed to do and women do it
a lot but no one wants that energy no
one it's not attractive it's it's not
productive it's not productive and
you're also trying to victimize yourself
for no reason and no one wants to
console you no it doesn't move the
conversation you don't need to apologize
it's better off just
gasping on some silence take a gulp of
air yeah because when you are overly
apologetic and anxious like that it's a
drain on other people did you just call
me another racial slur
what the fuck i gotta get like
see my assistant says she has to google
when she has to like
check the words that i say to her she
has to google them i feel like that with
you you say words that are like seven
syllables long and it's really rude did
you get your assistant from like an
exchange program
i mean
they need help
what was what were her qualifications um
she loved me where'd you find her
actually downstairs in your
comedy
adoptive
adopt a comic i know ron funches calls
me hoe rogan and it's really i know
bitch we need that murder i don't know
broken
it's just ah it's so good i um
so seeing you we are this is a we really
are jumping around because also i'm
getting distracted because i'm trying to
make a tequila drink which you're
failing at terribly because so far it's
just tequila which is really a tequila
okay but i'm trying to figure out what i
want to pair it with and my new thing is
to put
pomegranate juice with my tequila
because i feel like it
cancels it out can i see that
when i'm done pouring it
okay bitch bitch it feels like you're
drinking blood and tequila it really i
mean at this point might as well have
some red wines have you have you had
pomegranate juice is really good for you
it is really good i love pomegranates
but the way to what it takes to eat the
amount of arthritis you have to
get to eat one pomegranate it's such a
low yield it really is seeds i feel like
i i literally feel like i am people who
are starving discovered foods that are
so tedious to eat like an artichoke you
know hungry the motherfucker had to be
there's no artichokes it's not food it's
not food it's a cactus
there's no food in it show me how much
food comes from a artichoke i don't care
how much olive oil or parmesan cheese
you put on an artichoke there is nothing
there my mom used to steam artichokes
when i smell an artichoke till this day
you shit yourself i'm like is the
landlord yeah it's like the one it was
like you know everyone has a smell in
their house i had a friend that um her
mom got migraines from something so she
was always cooking cream of wheat and
when i smell that i'm like
right back there artichokes my mom would
um
say that for your only fans uh my mom
would make artichokes and then she would
have two little bowls one of melted
butter and one of sour cream oh and we
would just eat it but don't look at my
drip now you're looking right at my drip
i'm not looking at the drip on your chin
but it is going down towards your adam's
apple
and i see it but it also it now just
looks like a skin tag so please take it
off i think it's not no i'm keeping it
great for your brand thank you and so
i'm gonna come suck on my skin tag
and i remember because to this day i
think this is why i'm so obsessed with
condiments because i pretty much i dress
like that obviously we dress like them
and i also
for me food is just
the transportation device of a dip
it should be or a sauce it should be
it truly should be so i do like
artichokes and that you can i mean i
used to just scoop up sour cream and
just eat it that's delicious that's all
you're doing but i could have just used
a spoon why did i have to bring in your
weird doughnuts no you need to eat the
spoon the spoon has to be edible that's
the whole point like you need to have a
thing to scoop this there's no real meat
on that let's be honest what are we
doing well for me like when you smoke a
blunt food is like the accoutrement to
the blunt
it's really not about the food so about
the blunt that made the food taste so
amazing okay
yeah have you done one of those like uh
weed restaurant thing tastings of like
weed food yeah there was a place open in
california in los angeles lowell farms i
think yeah they do those they do um
great blunts that come in a free package
yes uh like cigarette case but it's
blunts and then on the and there's
matches that come with it yeah and then
this little um sandpaper on the top so
you can light it it's really cute and a
cute like little goat and a top hat i
really laughed and that's how cute they
were
i went there with josh wolfe and sarah
weinstein and we got stoned and
mac and cheese fun and then it shut down
because i i i don't know because so many
people died yeah i think everybody
everyone's dead yeah everyone died in a
car accident on the way
everyone drove off the pch after eating
that cannabis taco like easy guys that's
also what i call my pussy
honestly that's what a lot of people
call your pussy the cannabis taco yeah
oh god i'm hungry
okay i cut you off about well talking
about you meeting you yeah so i met you
and i was like she just seems too happy
i was just outside of the comedy store
out of the laugh act around that corner
you didn't say hi to me just so you just
walked by my joy i said hi you did i did
very briefly yes i wanted to suss you
out yeah and figure out what i'm up
against i remember that you were in
light jeans and you had a leather jacket
and i was
just confused by you
i like that
see
now she's fully brushing her hair you
guys listen this is how you cope you put
on your morning news anchor makeup in
front of everybody yes i did
would you okay stars are just like us
they
have to be stuck 17 by the way whitney
and i have so many animals
we have a lot of animals we have a lot
of animals i was thinking about this in
the way here we why are you saying we
like we're in a like a bitch don't jump
don't jump now
you're on a raft again please don't
point at me with my old dandruffy ass
hair brush oh all your witch hairs that
got burned off from your dirty ass
don't show my brush that is actually
really embarrassing
zoom in on the goddamn brush
this thing has been brushing the witch
hair that's been singed off
from her wizard staff that's from middle
earth it's flaking there are things
flaking it's it's isn't it just sticky
hairspray that burns on there you need
to send it to the cdc
this has been around so long it has
black hair in it and i haven't had black
hair for truly it's yours it's literally
showing all of your transformation
[Music]
is that the exoskeleton of a cricket
that's what i say every time i get on
stage okay
i threw away it's in the trash it's in
the trash isn't that cute this this can
it's got horses on it it's like 14 hands
winery unicorn rose bubbles i i i am not
this this should be stocked in your
house at all times i feel like just so
people um like try to do an intervention
of just
like your your loneliness is making
everyone uncomfortable can you just
behave less lonely do you feel like
you're lonely you don't give me lonely
time i'm really not yeah it's weird to
say i don't really get lonely i was
alone so much as a kid but i actually
i'm you know the the
definition of introvert and extrovert i
didn't understand that we were always
kind of confusing and getting wrong
introvert basically means that you
derive energy from being alone and
restoring yourself whereas extroverts
derive energy from socializing right my
girlfriend dory she you might be like
can go out and go to a dinner and then a
drinks and then an after party and then
wake up and go for a hike
like she'll hike with a friend i'm like
i when i'm like i'll do that like once a
week i can't every morning rotated like
i just can't be talking all the time
i have to take so much uh it takes me so
much time to recharge from social
interactions not as much anymore now
that i'm on prozac and then i've done a
lot of work on myself because it used to
i used to leave a social interaction
like that was so stupid why'd you say
that that was so stupid like that was
why did he look at you that way oh my
god you have to go back in there and
like tell her not to talk to you like
that like i just i would leave with
three hours of an emotional hangover
yeah and so i just couldn't socialize a
ton i feel the same like i feel i don't
know if it's introverted then where i
have to um really
a lot my social time
specifically nowadays
to where
social time i just say
energy it's it really it's your energy
it's energy energy in the preservation
of time my time so is this the time this
is my time it's so vital we're dying
when people around us die
then we are awoken to our mortality and
we're like oh damn this is it could go
tomorrow so what i'm doing today i need
to make sure that it's giving me some
extra energy for the next day
but or by the way just to think just to
do nothing just to stare it's like if
it's not a
hell yes it's a no yeah i heard someone
say that it changed my life oh my god
that's so good so it's like want to hang
out um that answers already no the
answer should be hell yeah i want to go
to that thing and if it's not just you
know i think it took me losing a parent
and i hope for most people it doesn't
take this i mean before that i was in
12-step programs for codependents
because i was doing things out of
obligation i was a perfectionist i was
mothering micromanaging and martyring
i'm you know i love attic shit i'm in
all these friendships with people i
don't even like i'm like they're like we
leave
drinks that i don't want to be at
they're like so you want to go hike this
weekend it's like
do you have any other questions for me
like i feel like you did it and then i
would go and then i'm like why am i
spending so much time and energy on this
friendship that depletes me i always
leave with this person feeling like shit
like they got they they used your energy
source to fulfill them vampires it's all
in exchange vampires something was said
but i also was saying yes and that's
dishonest
well you're so let me tell you something
i don't want to be friends is that is
that okay i'm going to leave
someone told me something
that i always think about when it comes
to energy and exchange and people and
spending your time with them there are
three types of people in the world one
when they come into a room they leave it
neutral
one when they come into a room they
leave it better and one when they come
into a room they leave it worse
and that's pretty much the exchange
between human beings and your whole life
you're like
is this person adding to my life taking
away or not giving me anything
and it goes to that whole hell yes thing
where it should be a fucking hell yes
the most like cliche thing we can say is
life is short well it is fucking short
it's unpredictable but it's also like
beautiful and chaotic and there's so
many amazing moments to have that why
not spend those moments with hell yes
people in your life like also there's
this um barry michaels and phil stutz
did he i'm actually gonna go i felt like
that was a really good cap thank you
everybody yeah no i just
that just feels like a perfect output
the snorting is so cute
i don't get out
of the house wait i'm obsessed with the
fact that you snort because a big
problem with my laughing is i laugh
silently i love your laugh you're loud
laugh i love your life but i laugh
silently some but other times i'm really
loud and then everyone used to make fun
of me when i was uh younger because i
would go i go like
like i have to take a big inhale
and thank god that's not happening
anymore
that's how i used to laugh it goes with
the curling iron
no that's what comes out of my lungs uh
what's on you
and so it's mold poisoning but i also
love that you say that because um
i also think it's nobody's fault if you
don't have if someone depletes you it's
not their fault it's not your fault
there also might just be a situation
where someone because usually when
someone is like very popular and has a
lot of friends i'm like
that person must be great because all
these people
like them so there must be something
wrong with me that i can't figure out
and then i try to hang out with them
like this is really hard for me and this
is really just not a match and you know
to outsource
what you believe the quality of a
friendship or a person is to outsource
it to other strangers is very stupid it
is really cool people we don't know vote
on things it doesn't always go the way
that works for us right so it's like um
so for me i finally got over the fact
like yeah this person everyone loves
them but for some reason we just can't
is that why i'm here always feels hard
so you're here so that i can practice
talking to people that i don't like that
i don't get along with so i can just
practice but it is that skill like
the faking thing i'm so no it's over
it's over and
can i tell you how and people that are
like you should be nice every now and
then because i'm almost the first person
that tells like you know um younger
people like sometimes you have to fake
it at work sometimes you have to pretend
you're having a good day when you're not
we don't we're lucky yeah we are lucky
our job is very specific and different
and we're our own bosses and we can
delegate you have to be responsible for
your energy and you cannot walk into a
work situation and bring everybody down
just because you're having a bad day
like this whole thing we're like i'm
being authentic okay you can be
authentic but at work you're getting
paid money
so don't
you can be fake every now and then as a
uh investment in your future stuff yes
jim saying just to be strategically yeah
we don't have to pick fights with
everybody at work because it is a
negative contribution to our future self
so actually sometimes being fake is
self-care it is and you're not going to
solve every problem with what you think
the other person needs to hear because
they might have the ability to digest it
and put it into use i have a person in
sort of our field that
did something really treacherous to me
like really like
dm'd a journalist saying i did something
tonight like something really hardcore
that someone that we're around a lot and
i hadn't been around this person for
you know because the pandemic and then i
saw this person after i and i you know
when you're like practicing in your head
the conversation you're going to have
with the person
it never comes out right it's always
better in the shower than in person but
i'm listening well if it comes out wrong
i'm like let me repeat myself yeah
and i'll say it again i like that let me
say it one more time so that you
understand yes i'll do a couple takes
yeah i'll do a couple takes yeah do not
interrupt me i know i'm saying the same
thing again in a different way and
better
i'm gonna get this shit right
like just give me one second it worked
in the shower this morning yeah yeah
i always have fake arguments in the car
in the shower and they're great and then
i get to the person it works on my
paddington bear
so i
go to a show she's there i'm in the car
on the car i'm in the car in the parking
lot with a friend of mine
oh the person is there shoot i shouldn't
have said that whatever that doesn't
narrow it down um there are more women
in comedy now than men i know there are
move over ladies and so i get in the
goddamn kitchen and look i'm in the
right
i could crush this person
i
would embarrass this person i would make
my point
but then what
then what
it doesn't make what happened
better not have happened your ego is
driving that shit the person that had to
do that
is
broken they're sad right like that is to
go out of your way to do something like
that and for me i was like the best
thing i can do for myself in this moment
is radically forgive we don't we forgive
others not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
yes and give this person a big hug
and say absolutely nothing because
the way that person
reacts i'm then going to have a problem
with the reaction and then i have a
problem with this and now everyone's
going to be talking about how whitney's
like stepped to somebody and probably
and like put a palm on her face and then
tipped her over slightly and like you
know all the things that i plan on my
head that i was going to do
and
i like the slight tip over it it's like
well it's a gravity it's just there but
it's just like a palm face palm it's
just okay
it's just so they have to do that and
look silly she's in like sneaker heels
or something yeah
all females in our business now kind of
wear the wedge heel yeah i put those up
those are up in the closet yeah
just for his wedge heels yeah they're
hung up i'm not doing it anymore i'm
done that's so funny though they're done
i love that you really did do that bitch
we all did i rolled my ankle a couple
times uh doing a joke about doggy style
and mommy had to retire them she's moved
on she's on flats she's on flats i love
steel wheels sneaker heels are my
favorite nails like eight pairs like
timberland heels bitch watch out jlo
from the block did it once she warm it
was over
moves over but wait but wait wait so i
show up and i'm like i'm like my ego
wants me to like get in this person's
face and say all the reason i'm right if
you're right and you're right with
yourself
you don't need to be you don't need to
defend yourself no
there's nothing to say no and people
that are right and people that are
right with themselves they don't go
around and telling people no so if
you're a nice person you don't go around
and tell everyone how nice you are if
you're uh my when people like look i'm
not crazy
no people that aren't crazy say that no
you don't need to you don't have to be
on the defense so i was like if i'm on
the defense there's something going on
with me where i feel like there's like a
glimmer of truth to this or i have so
much suspicion because i come from such
a
so many um
uh people that made bad decisions like
maybe i did do this bad thing maybe i am
just this person in my family maybe i
did inherit this thing and maybe i am
this evil person like something i i
needed something to prove something to
myself yeah my ego needed something my
inner child needed something and
whenever someone's about to do something
like that i always like to say like what
is the scenario in which you would get
exactly what you wanted out of this
exchange what is it it's never anything
good but you also can't come up with
that no you can't what's the best
there's
i'm sorry you're right
i
um
have a
what do i i can't even think of what i
wanted to say right i want to just
apologize and go i did that out of a fit
of anger and i'm now in a tough 12-step
program and i see what i did wrong and
this is a perfect time for you to
confront me in an alley because i
actually have my apology in my back
pocket and i'm so sorry and i have
donated to the don't ride elephants fund
and i just rescued a bunch of dogs
anymore
son of a bitch i know what am i going to
do in thailand you're going to ride um
the businessmen who go there from our
country yeah men dress like hell yeah
right
there you go
watch a documentary so i was just like
there's no version of this that's gonna
make me sleep better tonight right
there's no version that's healthy the
only thing i can do is
behave with dignity
and self-respect and not even dignify
this person with a conversation
right and it's always like i have the
refrain in my head just like fly high
fly high just fly high if people don't
like you it probably means you've made
it if someone's trying to dethrone what
you have or sabotage you that means you
have something to lose i know it just
still just it it it
it still just like
well i just go like it fucks with me
that someone took me like three days it
took me like three days to not because i
i will i go pretty
hard pretty fast if i'm if i don't have
the opportunity to like you know they
say every year that you're in a 12-step
program you get a second of pause
oh that math is terrible
fuck i'm gonna stick with tequila but
it's like to me because like don't just
do something sit there it's like if i a
lot of times the coda and alanon
addiction is taking an action i just
want to do something anything i'm going
to go to my ex's house i want to splash
his tires i just want to do something
to feel something else but what i'm
doing is really just exacerbating the
problem and making a negative
contribution i'm just making the problem
messier you're prolonging case yes i'm
just making it worse i'm just
exacerbating it i'm just like squeezing
the zit it's just going to go on longer
and longer and then i
can't have self-esteem because i did
something that wasn't an achievable
action so i was like okay always looking
for opportunities to build my
self-esteem the most esteemed thing i
can do right now is just have integrity
dignity focus on my job center love and
light bitch and
that's it put that on a mug sending me
love and like
big hug and move on and the phil stutz
and barry michael's book called the
tools there is something called the
death bed exercise there's a lot of
corny shit in that book but there's
something called the death bed exercise
that sounds like something we might need
your curling iron for
how many times can i bring that fucking
decrepit piece of material back i will
still have it on my deathbed so
um i actually stole it from my aunt's
deathbed uh 17 years ago
and so
if you imagine yourself on your deathbed
like what you're thinking and i have to
give credit to busy phillips who said
this one time when we were sort of
talking about food and you know when
you're like an obsession with food i've
like talked about my obsessions with
like eating store stuff where she just
said something she's like
i just feel like i don't be lying on my
deathbed regretting how much time i
wasted thinking about food
and i was just like oh shit like i did
it's the same about people though like
you don't want to like to your point you
don't want to be on your death bed
you're not going to be on your deathbed
thinking about the arguments it's not
going to be a bad it's going to be a
shower that i turn on but you'll be
beautiful and your makeup will be
perfect and it'll probably be the
curling iron in the tub i've been done
for 15 years wouldn't it be terrible if
you tried to kill yourself with a
curling iron but it died before you
this is the kind of lol you can only get
from comedians who have dead parents
because what you've seen is you're it's
over it's you're done you're basically
dead so there's nothing we walk around
the world like zombies just making
macabre jokes like this
it's honestly like
it's like where does the survival
and the art meet in that whole process
of making macabre things
material
you know and it's like when did that
like what was the gestation of that from
our youth into our career
because
that's essentially the core of what we
do
there was
a tumultuous life and chaotic household
and traumatic things that happened all
this darkness that sort of surrounded us
as people that the only way we could
cope was to make light of it and people
make light in different ways you paint
you make music you whatever it is you
sculpt or you tell jokes i've never
painted and felt better i i've never
sculpted anything you know what's weird
i don't know that much about what
happened to you oh that made you
think dating a borderline person or an
addict or someone that was a malignant
narcissist why that felt comfortable oh
my three my past three x's you just but
when basically titled see someone who's
in a bad relationship it took me so long
when has everyone been like this isn't
good for you and you're like you know
what
you're right it never happens and i'm
gonna stay in it nope
you're right seeing a couple years bitch
after i'm not even fertile anymore and
i've wasted seven years the best years
of my life with this guy with a chain
wallet here's a here's a plane ticket
for you to come peel me off my bathroom
floor
in guatemala for the fourth because his
wife doesn't like when i'm in the states
so when you see a friend in a bad
relationship a toxic relationship where
they're gone they are gone they are so
high on oxytocin and dopamine and that
and that bad dick and they
bad and i say bad in so many different
ways tell me oh you know like that bad
dick is like a good dick okay it's like
crack dick you're like you get on you're
like i know this isn't coming i've never
heard any of these terms well maybe i've
spent most of my life in the comedy
store bad electrical things
in your household right you know so what
i it's weird because i'm not a i go back
for the sex person
what are you i might go back for the
i i want to change you or you change i
do that too i definitely do that too i
love broken things
i like it's because it's you know what
it is it's sex feels good sometimes no
thank you i just want just pain just uh
just the impossible thing will never
happen i blew by myself with
i'm gonna try to change your entire
childhood and neural pathways with my
love yeah and i'm going to put all the
things about myself that i don't really
want to focus on fixing into you yep i
don't want you you're myself hgtv yeah
yeah i'm gonna fix you up i'm a tiny
house the fuck out of you
i'm an airbnb your soul someone's
someone says that we are going to flip
man
so whenever
i see someone
in a bad relationship like this i try to
say this to them because this is what
someone said to me and it blew my mind
it was i was
on a vacation with a guy which to me
vacations are just expensive places to
break up
and great lines it's so tell me you put
that in a special shut it out and you
should save it that's great okay
continue always crying at sandals
[Laughter]
there's your opening line well i'm
always crying in sandals at sandals
uh paid partnership with sandals um uh
diamonds
and
a woman said to me that i didn't know
sometimes you need someone that you do
not know that's why i sort of like say a
lot of these things on the show which
probably feel like platitudes or like
aphorisms or whatever i like to say a
lot because someone's a platitude it's
like you're saying something that's like
you can only
get what you give
things that you've heard a lot that are
true but they've been said so much that
they sort of feel corny
cliche or something yeah it's um treat
uh people the way you want to be treated
like life is short what's that life is
sure little things like that where
you've heard it from people
like adults and then as you get older
you realize adults are flawed and you're
like why did i listen to you about any
of that shit y'all are nuts you guys are
just reading me stuff from a maya
angelou poem yeah that was from a
fortune cookie from a restaurant you
didn't pay the bill out and we had just
you made me run out last you were crying
yeah dad wasn't there and you're with
dad's brother and you made me steal the
fortune cookie
i had to put it in my little vagina i
could bless myself so you can have that
portion my
[Laughter]
it's also displaying the colors we're
both wearing which i just realized
rust and mustard that's the thing that
we were calling so disgusting matches
both of our shirts should we call our
band rustered
uh-oh
i know i am coughing a lot yeah don't
quit spraying it this way bitch so what
i say is um
if this per the person you're with
because a lot of people go like he's
such a great guy and like when he gets
out of this thing and i think when he
graduates or like once once he's out of
school or like once he gets out with his
parents or the moment you need to like
validate or quantify what's going on
he's so
like he's just going no he gets really
insecure and probably he does he has
really bad jokes you just can't bring
him here yeah and you know if he's just
you know what he just he hasn't don't
mention the word crocs yeah yeah and you
can't really look him in the eye no
he'll try to have something he only has
one he lost it but he tries to have sex
with you you can't you just can't look
at him but now it's on you he would have
a few banks but it was way back in the
day yeah yeah but he doesn't call me
back because he's busy he's busy oh my
god thank you he owns his own company
and he doesn't have to bother that
because he's
ego friendly
and she's got he gave it to her
he's not sexist he thinks women can
drive
so he gives her his car by the way the
man's a hero we've said something that
every woman who's watching has at least
someone has said the way that you're
able to defend something are you
lotioning i am lubing up i am putting on
what's going to happen i don't know i'm
putting on bodies coming in here i feel
like something's going to happen why is
your trash can open
because there's a couple more curling
iron or something you should throw in
there
how did you notice that because i'm
worried i don't know why you're
moisturizing i'm always i'm always
moisturizing i don't dry
you know that i reapply face oil at
night in the middle of the night when i
go to the bathroom i know i have
actually how many times have i asked you
about your skincare regime too many
times that's rude yeah yeah that's rude
could you maybe take a note or two just
write it down screen grabbing
i took a screen grab your skin looks
sick thank you
are those your actual nails yeah and i'm
drooling again that is stop it i try
well i try to make a joke and that's
where all this is they should keep it in
because it look like a fucking asshole
because everything's spilled all over me
these are my nails
death vitamins
is that a vitamin company it should be
wait we should start it that's genius
death vitamins that's genius i'm not
even joking well we should cut it out we
should start it okay well no we put it
in when people die these are the
vitamins you need to take because the
stress of the death is gonna cause your
ass to go crazy at least you have nice
nails
we'll workshop it we'll workshop it
you're the person
who you love correct if you were you're
the you're the bitch that so if you
weren't doing stand-up
if it didn't happen or it wasn't a thing
right
you'd be the bitch that like comes up
with the wildest shit and you know when
like something's marketed to you in a
weird way and you're like what dickhead
what like do you you know amazon now
sends you packages with a
poster of their movies on it or
something yeah what is that where you
just have to stab into chris pratt's
face and then slash getting slapped and
then put it in the garbage it feels
right jeff bezos is like guys we need
some ideas on how no one's watching our
tv shows we have a tv network now we've
got mays all we've got all these videos
trip to the moon in a week we got all
these stars i gotta get to the moon any
minute now and we need to my wife
divorced me and she took everything well
you're the biggest thing
what do we just put the posters on the
boxes
yes
i was like um stoner in the fucking
storage room i feel like we'd have to
run that by chris pratt's people do you
think that's why they stopped testing
for weeds because a pot had came up with
that idea and they're like
we're not testing for it anymore what if
the box is full of lube like who knows
what's in the box like do we have to
match who's on the poster of the box the
box should always be filled with lube
full just in general just
and like you're the one that comes up
with that crazy shit i love creating
crazy ideas here's this here's a female
question
if you're with your a man who you're
sexually attracted to and your vagina
completely dries up
even though you're attracted to him does
that mean that emotionally he's not
compatible with you
and maybe your vagina's trying to send
you a message like bitch we're good
define completely dried up i mean like
we are the most hydrated bitches in the
game oh that's such a bummer like a like
a like a river rat yeah when you're um
like like a a woodland creek like a like
i do this to my dude all the time i'm
like would you date me if i look like
this you look like you're from fucking a
different state like ohio would you date
me if i look like this i would date you
either way
i would you look like every girl who
first gets to l.a
[Music]
oh i'm sorry
see
i unleashed i unleashed on rogan but
this is a different unleashing
so i know i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
ride this version of jessie may i'm
riding this virgin i'm riding the horse
in the direction it is going she's
unleashing me so yeah although he's like
would you like
this i'll be like would you love me if i
look like this that's
hard no but he'll just say no i'm like
you're supposed to say yes he's like
this feels like a trap the lip the lip i
would but the nose is where you really
threw me off here the lip in the nose is
too much that yes one of my idols
yesterday told me i look like a horse
was it was it
i can't tell you who come bitch there's
so many secrets i can't tell you who
just know it was someone i really look
up to and it was out of denny's
i don't know why you
the person you would look up to would
dine at denny's i think you really need
to reassess work on my heroes yeah i
don't know and they say never meet your
heroes at denny's
that's where the the thing got cut off
you should meet your heroes just not at
denny's that's where you fucked up but
you know what i feel like i am the bitch
that looks up to people that eat at
denny's if someone's like i'm going to
the chateau merman i'm like
yeah but then what if you saw like that
person who you s who secure people go to
denny's
i mean i went to a denny's once and i
crawled out of that motherfucker and and
i i didn't get up for two days you know
i actually crawled across a parking lot
into a walgreens and a mother and
daughter stepped over me like i was a
crackhead all from denny's sure what did
you order
crack moon's over my hammy next thing i
knew super poops
soupy poo won't be at coachella you're
welcome
[Music]
crikey we now take a break from these
two lappies yapping at each other to
take some mental health questions from
the good for you fans i'm steve owen the
crocodile hunter himself well i'm a
ghost but thankfully this place has got
some great lighting
first we got a question from jennifer in
milwaukee
well
i feel like i'm struggling
to make my dreams happen it feels like
all my friends are more successful than
me
it makes me feel anxious and depressed
on how to cope
i mean i think she's asking you like how
to cope with all of that well it seems
like the first thing you need to do is
work on your gratitude practice take the
day off get some sun go to the beach but
do not go
in the water by any circumstances or
you'll be impaled in the chest by a
flying underwater sword
sorry that was probably not useful let
me put it in simple terms so you can
understand okay the stingray injury is
caused by a venomous trail spines
stingers or dermal tentacles listen
stingrays generally do not attack
aggressively or even actively defend
themselves unless it's me
and there is three cameras around
embarrassing
the next question is caroline from
florida
i'm extremely shy and it keeps me from
making friends and doing a lot of things
i really would love to do in my life
any advice on how to take charge of my
life and be more outgoing
me i'd love to know right mate see
depending on the size of the stingray
humans are usually stung in the lower
limb you know the lower limb region
usually occur when you know swimmers or
divers accidentally step on a stingray i
don't think that's what she was asking
what's next um
okay is there there's another question
for her
i don't think we answered her question
but there's one more well you know you
know i am anyway everyone's this one's
also she's saying everyone's always
talking you know about red flags
and how we should ignore them yup well
but i feel like everything is always a
red flag you know oh i'm constantly you
know riddled with social anxiety and how
do i deal with that you know crikey
that's a good question
well fatal stings are very rare i was i
was only the second case recorded in
australia since
1945. anyways chin up and keep on
exploring my crikey okay um
if you need help navigating something in
your life that doesn't involve avoiding
death by stingrays then you should check
out betterhelp.com betterhelp that's
betterhelp help they will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
why do ghosts do thumbs-ups
[Laughter]
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online luckily this
podcast is sponsored by better help and
good for you listeners get 10 off their
first month betterhelp.com whitney
you're better get better health
it's better
crikey
better diving choice
well my name's ray stingray
crikey that was specific advice
crikey it was hard to listen to you do
that accent
earnestly sorry i'm being earnest oh
i'm just i'm so good i love
that what earnestly earnestly i'm just
trying to that's why you're you and i me
i couldn't i didn't think of that and
we're all each other but you did think
of the starbucks mermaid joke you know
what someone on your instagram commented
commented tell her that's a good joke
and i thought don't worry girl i read it
and then you went to that person's
instagram page and it was carrot top
so we've talked about earnest quite a
lot it is a company that helps you
refinance your student loans pay your
student loans i just had a rude
awakening a reawakening frankly i
already knew that student debt was
debilitatingly annoying and frustrating
but uh so am i as a girlfriend
and the other day we were flying to las
vegas
america and i
left my
driver's license in a little bag we went
to paris hilton's house and i was trying
so hard to be cute with my little bag
because i didn't want to bring my big
clear one that i buy on costco because i
need to be able to see what's in my
purse anyway so you know when you
transfer something from one purse to
another person you forget whole new life
so we have 30 minutes until the flight
takes off i call my lover and i'm like
hey there's no easy way to say this i
need my license in like 20 minutes
could you get it for me
this legend of a
lad
gets it
comes brings it to me and of course when
you're in that much of a rush like yeah
just give it to me i'm sorry even though
they're doing the nicest thing for you
you're like trying so hard to be nice
but i'm like just yeah i gotta go and
they're freaking me out and i can't get
on the plane this whole thing and i said
to him i was like i love you so much
thank you so much for doing this this is
such a game changer what can i do to
repay you how about i just pay off your
student loans
okay i said it in the fit of gratitude
okay and it was also very hot at that
airport so i was a little dizzy i was
like oh you know what baby i love you so
much i'm just gonna pay for student
loans and he goes oh it's fine they're
not that much anymore and i was like oh
perfect
perfect time to offer what are they 5k
10k i was like okay how much are they he
goes they're about 58k i was like
uh
never mind that's insane i just can't
that to me just the fact that his face
was so like ah they're not that much
that just goes to show you
how insane
student loans crazy my student loans are
more than that and i'm not even a doctor
well laughter is the best medicine so so
you are
emily
what do you have to say about yourself
ernest is offering our listeners a
hundred dollar cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com whitney
terms and condition supply now ernest is
giving our listeners a hundred dollar
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com
wait wait wait wait emily
do terms and conditions apply by any
chance terms and conditions apply once
again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit
earnest.com whitney to refinance your
student loan not available in all states
terms and conditions
apply the real question is if your hero
wants to meet with denny's
the question is
is that their only option or is that a
choice because it's fun that's a good
question because if they're a hero
they might have to go to danny if
they're like do you want to go to sunset
tower or denny's that's cool but if it's
like you would always choose denny's
daddy well of course but i don't yeah i
don't want to deal with running into all
the people in hollywood that i've fired
that have like given me really weird
long hugs at the farmer's market on
weekends
i'm actually okay in the front in the in
the when the pelvis your butt should be
out but when the when it gets thrusted
into your
coma
like can you get your suit out of me
get your suit out of my how many times
if if harvey weinstein had a doll
if he had a doll i have a dollar if he
had a dollar by the way
can you get your suit out of me yeah he
never wore suits no he didn't huh but i
almost called him herbie weinstein
because remember that movie herbie fully
loaded i think he did it i saw him at
the premiere of her be fully loaded yeah
herbie weinstein that sometimes just
mispronouncing someone's name is the
best burn you can possibly do i think
watching him walk out on walkers with
tennis balls on the bottom
it filled me with an inhalation i hadn't
felt like i know everyone who was like a
rapist and managed to like bang down
doors to rape people as soon as they get
charged they had they're like in a
wheelchair stress and the truth are a
big i know
cosby's got
[Music]
so before cosby got out i was trying to
work on a joke about how um
now that the dust is settled
now that we all agree
that this guy's a monster i feel like
i've been very clear on my stance about
this
monster bad rod in jail kill him give
him the epstein treatment i don't care
is it time that we can talk about how
the victims of cosby
wanted to have consensual sex with
america's
dad that's not what they got
but that is what they were going for
which actually seems a little bit worse
[Laughter]
so i was like
now that all the dust is settled
like what a hot taste it's a hot take
but but i just want to go oh baby baby i
would have been one of those people too
as a woman maybe just take a look
as a woman i think it's important and
with anything that comes up that's
controversial like that where america's
dad does something
that is just so
vile
we can't lean on one side of it we have
to as a society and as people as a whole
open up those
terrible boxes and go well here's the
kind of did you say i have a terrible
box no that's you projecting you're the
one that just said yours was dry but my
are you writing down that are you
writing down dry i'm writing down i'm
i'm working on my suicide note leave me
alone
i did just write dry vagina no i was
going to say yours probably looks like a
really nice macaroon from a very
expensive bakery
it looks like an impossible burger
don't eat those those are so bad though
i like them no they have them at burger
king if they sponsor you i'm very happy
for you no they don't okay well you
probably shouldn't eat them why the
chemicals of the impossible burger do do
vegan meat isolate the isolate what's
isolate there's a there's a chemical in
there it's a little carcinogenic
bitch i'm involved i'm sorry are you i
drink decaf coffee for 20 years and then
someone's like you know that has
formaldehyde in it right and i was like
what yeah decaf coffee has that's how
they get the coffee out no that wasn't
from the coffee that was from your
fucking curling iron
no that was actually just from the
formaldehyde that i soak in every night
i don't know i'm just i'm trying to talk
about the doctor i'm just a little bit
like
that ship has said you know i'm just a
little bit like okay the stress
of running around and trying to eat the
healthy thing the release of cortisone
is actually worse for us than just
eating the bad thing
it is i just can't think about food
anymore i'm 38 years old i never
literally never want to think about it
again who gives a fuck last night i ate
tater tots from four days ago at two in
the morning can we put my foot up what
oh jesus christ
okay keep going i've got it i've got her
her show is called
horrible tattoos what's it called and
i'll show you mine it's right there
you know that most of my tattoos are
white i want to see your face i regret
it no what do you mean i would love to
but no look no i just i was just saying
it was just funny can you keep it there
forever no every joke has a little truth
behind it
it's fine now i get it i love the photo
you have for your podcast
all right i was going to change it
okay i mean it is appropriate and you
will get cancelled but
the cornrows maybe do it without
cornrows it's basically all the guys
that i've dated that's what kind of what
they look like okay you keep bringing i
want to know why did this happen there
are girls that you did
that are in bad it took me so long to
realize why i was attracted to people
who have the negative qualities of my
primary caretaker and here's what i will
say okay
i think it hot take hottest take of the
day which is if you're dating a bunch of
malignant narcissists and your ex is a
psycho and your ex is a psycho like
who's the common denominator and this is
what's going on with you because i think
it feels really good to go like that
guy's a dick and he was an asshole and
he did this and this like so you had no
parts right you had no so every day you
got in the car you put on your pants you
put on your wireless bra you put on
you're bumping in
you know you drove to his house if he's
such a psycho and such an asshole why'd
you keep showing up what's going on with
us and with blame blameless inventory
and compassion we can go okay
why is your inner child am i occurring
that that's actually safe yeah why what
what are we getting out of this what is
it is it adrenaline is it that's usually
what it is my addiction main addiction
is taking an action and adrenaline and
also chasing someone who's unavailable
oh yeah because i believe when you meet
someone they tell you everything you
need to know about them they do without
but we won't be saying a lot we won't
believe it i think you know what i
realized most recently something i've
been doing every day since my mom died
which is november 13th friday 13th of
spooky spooky very spooky did she hold
off she's a big halloween person she's
just very you know sardonic like here
you go you won't be able to forget this
bitch um
i meditate every morning and i write
after
and sometimes how long do you meditate
between 15 and half an hour do you have
a mantra
do you just go back
actually i don't but i've worked so that
when i kegel it will pop up topic oh
smart smart sponsor yeah yeah
i've never been able to say queef
without stuttering and it's such a
bummer you know when you have a banger
like a joke i'm not saying it's gray but
it wouldn't and you mean when i turned
water all over my face before
you know when you flub it i know i've
done it like sorry lucille ball over
here um but but when you flub you're
like and then
you try so hard to get to it quickly or
when you send it like a good burn on
text and there's a typo fucks it up and
you're like oh your eyes it's the worst
it could be so perfect
yeah anyway uh back to my trauma
um
the quick version and you can you can
dive into whatever you want like what
pattern did you recreate like and you
don't have to over over this right so i
today when i was meditating i realized
that
um
as much as i loved my father and how
amazing he was and he was a very present
father
early on in my
youth as a kid i realized
he was emotionally unavailable
and that's one of the things that drove
my mom to move the neighbor's dad in
um
that was her throat
reacting to my throat upstate
mathematics queefed as i processed that
clip it that was like old cum that like
hadn't been excavated from years ago i
don't know what it was
your
neighbor
yeah
i truly want that to be my ringtone i
can't believe you just said
but
i'm sorry i meant to say fossilized cum
congealed coagulated too far but here's
what i'll take too far i do think most
of our fathers if i may i'm 38 me too
most of them their parents were either
in wars had no tools did not have better
help didn't do didn't like they weren't
encouraged to discuss nope
on a bare minimum it was man up when
boys today hopefully you have a boy you
don't go you don't go don't cry you go
why are you crying and i think the boys
why aren't you crying i just hit you
across the face
do you have autism
the boys of yesteryear were
like don't cry don't cry it's it's you
know they were told they were told and
taught to
castrate their emotions which is so
ironic sorry i feel like a lot of people
use that word incorrectly and i don't
want to be one of those people um ironic
and random are just thrown around now in
a way that's like so confusing to me oh
honest more said nailed it yeah well
don't you think
and i feel like
there's two conflicting definitions of
masculinity it's like made it up never
show your feelings never feel pain like
white knuckle through it but then the
other one is you have to be courageous
and you have to take risks the most
courageous thing you can do as a man is
cry just not while you're inside of us
that's gross please don't do that no you
gotta separate you gotta
unless you need some lube and a jiffy i
um yes i just realized that my dad even
though
i think we do this often as people we
idolize our parents and we sort of put
them on a pedestal and
our memories of them are sort of
grandiose sometimes and my dad wasn't
the most emotionally available and i
think i always sought those out as
you know elementary as it sounds i was
just comfortable it's comfortable you're
recreating a childhood pattern that you
would very well adapt to it's like it's
like stepping in a shoe that you've worn
a lot yeah and it doesn't give you
blisters it fits even if it's the most
psychotically painful seven you're sick
yeah but if your body and your emotions
and your brain have morph to accommodate
it
everything else is uncomfortable yeah
it's uncomfortable to be loved it's
uncomfortable to have someone present
you know i i had that too i had such
like neglect and someone emotionally
available that when someone actually
does love me i'm like what are you doing
what do you why do you they're like
how's your day i'm like who's asking
like why do you want to know yeah what
do you fucking fbi do you need a cop
yeah what'd you do
a guy would give me flowers i'd be like
what did you do yeah
yeah because i only would get gifts as a
pr as a kid and presents if something
was something that has a great gesture
right as a distraction and their shame
thing of like i was ignored you for two
weeks but here's a pretty sparkly thing
right so that you sort of forget all of
that and that conditioning is so fucking
toxic so toxic and you know my
upbringing
was
filled with love but because i'm from
upstate new york
that's always weird to me is it that
yeah i just i don't
it why did i put that on you that i
didn't when i first met you i got out
young yeah i got out very young okay i
got it right when i turned 18. okay
i went to boston okay with a boyfriend
who i'm still friends with probably the
nicest sweetest man
that i have ever dated
he was the last of the mohicans he was
an introduction to what healthy love was
and i was like this is fun but boring
so i'm going to do what everyone do
where's the toxicity where's the plot
i'm going to do what everyone did uh to
the mohicans and steal his time
waste his life rape and pillages people
and burns and then leave him for just
doing everything right yeah leave him in
the dust you weren't ready to receive i
was yeah and you know my parents both
loved me you know it was a very um
weird dichotomy between my father's
emotional unavailability and my mother
being a little reckless with
you know moving in literally four houses
down their dad moved into our house and
he's still there he's a great guy he's
my stepdad now he's my last living
parent okay um but that whole wait so
did your dad move out yeah my dad moved
out yeah we didn't have like a you know
super like hippie existence or my dad's
like it's cool steve's here you know my
dad you're not ashton coach and bruce
willis no no yeah he left he went and
stayed
at his mother's house and lived in a her
small closet on a twin mattress on the
floor until he could afford a house
close to us and then my father bought a
house that was like three blocks down in
in
you know when i i'm so sorry when i
think about that is love to me yeah you
might have heard i love you every day
you might not have gotten a a little
tickle
um hopefully sorry like you know i got
those from my own sorry i was i was
trying to think of like dads what did i
i
what do dads do with their kids they
like throw football
yeah especially daughters like
the the father-daughter dynamic is so so
awkward it's so awkward
and you're either a person or tomboy yep
you know it's a very hard place i
remember my dad and i i was like whitney
bear we but when i remember the first
time we were watching tv we would always
watch three's company together
and that was kind of like our thing
i had no idea all the sexual innuendo
and stuff but so many i just you know he
was so brilliant on everyone you
couldn't make that show today you
couldn't you couldn't people love seeing
that maybe you could who cares why would
you want to i mean that's the other
thing when something you couldn't say
that on stage like do you want to say
that yeah fuck it let it little bit let
me hear the bit yeah
you need to say this so bad yeah we
can't say tranny anymore what was your
bit
that you needed to say that i would love
to hear it and then and then let's see
if it's worth it
how you all you do is jokes about
airplane food why are you worried about
not being able to say certain words
you've been written into a joke in 40
years well
i know it's not about me because i'm not
40 yet i just mean like you know when
you talk to comics and like dude we
can't even say you know gay anymore i'm
like what was the joke yeah why why are
you so attached to it are you yeah like
what was if you're true how much is
being taken from you right that you
can't say that right evolve
gary
it's just a gary
who's never on the road to name a horse
gary so bad
so well there's six of them in the
backyard i can pick from
so your dad used to watch
we watched his company yes i remember i
felt very close to him and very
connected to him and then
we watched a tampon commercial together
and it was over
it was like
ugh like i ran out of the room i was so
embarrassed i was probably like 12. i
don't think i even had my period yet but
i was just like
he knows i have a vagina like i
thought that's
why i thought that's when he found out
you know what i mean that i had i was
just like oh okay he knows his vagina he
knows things go inside of it and and i
also the bigger problem was that i was
learning that period blood is blue uh
which took me a long time to learn
remember those tampon commercials where
they would pour it out that's right it
would be like a little vial that would
go on always with wings and it would be
blue and then on my period and i'm like
that's right and they wonder why we're
crazy how traumatizing that was yeah
it's like it's red i'm not even a lie
yeah oh no i'm dying i fully thought
that i was just passing on crossing over
yes because i thought it was supposed to
be blue because that's what it was in
the commercials i never even thought
about that subliminal damage that's done
from that yes like just sort of watch so
many little
teeny things like these little injuries
that happen to women along the way that
are so subliminal and so quiet
that they finally accumulate to
something and then we're the crazy bitch
i know i would see like like blueberry
kool-aid they're like why is there a
glass full of blood in here
don't drink that
you vampire
yes your tampon busted the wall i look
it's all blue i think about so many
things like that like i truly toys r us
i was like i used to write my ours
backwards in school yeah that's right
because i would like to fail the test
and i was like well this is the name of
toys r us this is our this is our this
is our mecca this is where we go to find
joy and backwards and toys r us like
what that's some shit
what do we put the r backwards bro it's
not a logo until you flip the r
you guys are just start seeing it moron
you know what let's just flip the r
these are children that are learning to
read let's just hi boy you need to flip
the arts just flip the r
brutal
but
you were saying when you were sitting
with your dad watching these shows there
was a point it was
awkward like it was just it's we it's
just there's something and my dad was
very
this is going to sound great hot like
he's kind he was like i know that's hard
like he was so charismatic and funny
like waitresses love to like everyone
just loved him yeah you know he was just
a he was he looked like dan aykroyd he
was so funny he was so charming he had
been all over the country for his job
and every time he met someone he would
talk to every single person whether it
was the waitress or the hostess or that
my dad would do the same he would stop
you go hey man where are you from my dad
would do the same
thing hey man where are you from they go
um
new jersey they're like ah what's orange
45th street there's that hot dog place
you go i love that place so yeah dude
have you been back is it still open it's
so wild he could make someone his best
friend
right away
he cared yeah you really want to know
everyone feels seen
truly wanted to know the answer though
that's so wild my dad would do that too
i remember i he brought me to his bar
once
and this really tall woman walked up
here he ran a bar yeah no he just was
there every day oh god um change of pace
shout out to changing pace in syracuse
yep um for killing my dad with your
liquor yeah for uh it's your fault that
he hasn't hit him with us i hope you're
still keeping his chair yeah yeah i
hope you're still keeping his chair
right russians were worth it my dad
would just drink vodka soda lime and he
would have the waitress or the bartender
keep the same drink
and just add the lime so he could count
his drinks at the end of the night by
the amount of limes he had in the one
glass and that's when he knew when it
was time to go home when the glass was
filled with lines
should your next book be called
limelight
about how your dads went to the life
alcoholism
made you a star
this super tall woman walked up my dad
used to love to crack jokes that was his
thing like it was the same thing in the
family
honestly i'm just hanging out with you
because i know i can go straight excuse
me i'm busy reading it by the way just a
real so many sugars real comedian we are
going deep
is this my water i think you can joke
about anything as long as it's with
respect and yes are you oh you now need
to hydrate that reminds me i just love
drinks but that reminds me of your pussy
why is it dry are you dehydrated oh
that's right clearly not right okay so i
have answered that question did you
write that down dry vagina yeah it's
written down you didn't answer the
question
which was well it warranted a little
more real estate
is that why we're going back into my
youth well no i'm trying to learn about
you
while being monetized these are
questions i wouldn't ask if we
sounds like something hitler said to
people uh
and i'm here for it
what that's interesting because you are
so um
clear to me and you're so self
self-contained is a word i like to use
but you know exactly who you are
you don't operate from a place of shame
that's part of the reason why i met you
i was like i don't get this i don't know
i don't know how to get in with her you
know because by the time the first time
i met you the only way i was able to
connect with people was through trauma
dysfunction
wow flirting like i didn't oh i didn't
even get a flirt yeah no i didn't know
hard times you were on girl code and i
just don't
what finger girls and when did you just
sweat it out for a little bit no i was
gonna date someone who was making mtv
money
i don't date those snail bitches
grocery store lemonade
that is simply lemonade it is
12 juice in here that is 12
juice
like your pussy why is there only 12
percent why why does it get dry with
somebody who you're attracted to so
you're dating somebody and it gets dry
let's let's i mean this is a
hypothetical i'm a fan of a pussy being
dry when you're not having sex
yeah okay yeah yeah okay from a sanitary
level yeah i don't want to be dripping
like
throughout the day i can't just be full
swamp ass all the time no but we have
that if you're wet all the time
me know your secrets pull it back i
don't know
in glorious they're absorbent i feel
like eva longoria is wet all the time i
for like i just love her the weirdest
reference she's so badass do you know
she taught herself like two languages
and got a degree while she was filming
desperate housewives i didn't know that
because all the down time on set come on
what
my face
no your face oh we have to get your skin
we have a lot of things no saying come
on my face just okay um
i will as soon as i can figure out how
to squirt it soon we're not there yet
i can't
you look like you teach huge you look
like you're going to a photo shoot and
they're like dressed like you train
horses but you don't know what you're
doing
dress like you're the fake horse trainer
on epstein island who really has no idea
what they're doing but just doesn't
matter they're never going to get there
uh they're not going to get to this
table
side note which i we're juggling between
80d and sidenote for the title of this
podcast your instagram videos back in
the day of your horse muddy
just not giving you anything made me cry
like your horse being like no thanks
like you being denied a horse
look i've decided bad of a person or are
you i'm clearly not
a hollywood big wig because i have
decided my relationship with the love of
my life is gonna be consensual
and you can't fuck your horse in the
beginning look
i can't
and i won't
but i can and i won't
but if the world shuts down again
uh a horse is a horse of course of
course content is content
and
happy hands did not go viral i am very
close to getting that only fans money
and i mean
like that energy i think only fans is
real and i think we should be doing it
oh i meant like you're in love with the
horse and i don't know
well now we're on two days that was the
rorschach chess
damn it
you were so close let me brush it and
you can try that is a rorschach test
that i failed miserably you're
you're baiter mind-hoffing me right now
what's that it's that thing where you
hear something and then you see it
everywhere
the bader-meinhof phenomenon yes where
you like hear a word you've never heard
and then all of a sudden it's in
nineteen everywhere what is that it's uh
is it because you're actually looking
for it and it's top of hippocampus
it it is and it's also it's it goes back
to like the rgb uh uh
the russian secret spy they got it
meinhof phenomenon came out of the red
army faction i'm fascinated by this shit
i am too anything that has to do with
like psychology or reasons why we do
things or west german far left militant
organization founded in 1970
um
with whitney's curling is your curling
iron
i don't know if you should plug that in
where is that coming from
key figures included blah blah blah all
these guys that were probably not great
people the government of the federal
republic of germany as well as the
western media literature consider the
red army faction to be a terrorist
organization why did you bring your
dildo with you to the show today oh i
don't know it was just in the corner and
i i didn't want the sun to hit my face i
do not have sex with my horse but i do
use that when times are tough this is
definitely something that could prop me
up i would sit on this and twirl yeah on
a lonely and a lonely quarantine eve
continue reading
army faction engaged in a series of
bombings assassinations kidnappings bank
robberies and shootouts oh how charming
with police over the course of the
decades
but why does this matter with the
there was something that happened
in there
wait the excuse me okay
you know what if you've see oh acts of
terrorism the bader minhov there we go
gang has been associated with various
acts of terrorism since their founding
their first act of terrorism attributed
is it attributed or attributed it
depends on how many tequilas you've had
to there are two to the group after the
student ben
is this a prank these are all german
names i have the same thing when i walk
down here and they have a little doctor
they have dots over there this does not
feel fair
uh they cause property damage okay uh
uh german autumn this all i don't know
it's a lot it's a lot also basically
says my dad's name is vince so well and
like this page is very long can we get
like a concise situation
illusion i like that that's the more
popular term also known as the bader
meinhof phenomenon it's a cognitive bias
in which after noticing something for
the first time there is a tendency to
notice it more often leading someone to
believe that it has high frequency a
firm of social bias it occurs when
increased awareness of something creates
the illusion that it is appearing more
often put plainly the frequency illusion
is when a quote concept or thing just
found out about suddenly seems to crop
up everywhere okay so this feels like
gas lighting it is like gaslighting and
i feel like um and i'm gonna really i'm
really gonna hit a hit a nerve here i
feel like this is a
a situation that sometimes people take
advantage of are people who are
vulnerable after somebody dies
because when somebody dies you see signs
and i don't know what happens after
somebody dies are they still living are
ghosts really a thing but we see signs
that sort of remind us of them
and in my mind because we're already
primed to be thinking about them yes all
of a sudden it's like oh my god an ice
cream shop he loved ice cream oh we
loved it yeah there's you know a
hummingbird that visits me every morning
there's a tree his house was made of
wood yeah it's always like and i think
of course we want to believe i want to
believe but i think that the more like
prosaic or common way that this is is if
you see a word like if i see a word
defenestrate or something and i'm like
what's that bitch that's just rude
who
sorry defender straight how dare you was
it that just was that something
something my drunk aunt used to say in
the morning
to get me to help her get her pants
we're just finished straightening jeans
was she a russian
schizophrenic yes but woman with bell's
palsy wow
this is called exposure
really real exposure therapy we go there
we go there
so
you know you'll see
because i remember when i was reading
super sad true love story by gary
steingard he's easily my favorite author
there was a word on every page of that
book that i have never
heard of did it start with his last name
gary steinger we've worked together
s-h-t-y-n-g-a-r-d-t
i want to say that he's scandinavia he's
russian he's a russian and yeah it's
there's like not a vowel in sight
and so i would look up words because i
was like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go
past a word that i don't know i'm gonna
learn it i'm trying to lock it in i
remember there's a word defenestrate
which means to throw out of a window oh
so
so what a lot of people do with their
kids which i had to do once when i
pooped in a guy's bathroom in my 20s and
it didn't flush and i scooped it out
with a ziplock and threw it out the
window
i defended actually that's patreon
material i think it's a patreon clip i
don't know if you want to put that out
there
but you scooped your poop and flipped it
out you've never done that no i let it
float let them know i'm a badass
let them know there's room in there is
there a problem here let them know that
we just evacuated some space is
available yes something happens there's
a vacant suggestion there's a vacancy in
there
there's vacant what are you gonna do
there's some room in my ass
are you gonna be worried about the
floating poop are you ass eating
currently
because miss pat miss pat's daughter was
like if you eat ass you will get
proposed to in three months i mean
i don't know if i want to be engaged in
that person yes i don't do it i i'll do
a lot i put up with a lot i do too i
wore nipple clamps with feathers on it
i'm here for that i was that's a tuesday
breakfast i was not a fan really um
it sounds fun it had feathers and bells
well that just sounds like a little
salvation army people at the mall that's
like an aunt who's like i'm an artist
but she just spends all her money at
jonah joanne fabrics
[Laughter]
or she's the aunt that just takes purses
she's like give me your purse i'll paint
something on it
you're like oh here we go
like cool
you know what would make your favorite
purse even cooler participating me
painting
uh with paint that will crust off like
whitney's curling iron hair to paint
a stargazer lily
on your louis bag i have a stargazer's
one of my tattoos
is that true that was my aunt's wedding
flower and i'm gonna have it in my
wedding oh
those will be my wedding flowers these
were my mom's flowers in the backyard so
i got it oh my god and you know that
when you have them the pollen goes
everywhere and ruins everything it is
the first room when you get a stargazer
lily you have to take all the pollen off
yeah it will stain yeah it will look
like you had a dirty dancing abortion
it's a very strong floral cum mm-hmm but
they're so beautiful they're so and they
smell so fragrant wow that's weird that
is weird super weird am i gonna
officiate i think they're also called
who would officiate your wedding that's
a great
everyone questions uh who would
officiate my wedding well everyone i
love is dead
um
wow it's also called a red lip red
red rum lily r-e-b-r-u-m it is
i obviously don't read too much but how
about the fact that i went on a little
trip with my guy
uh my lover
and we're walking around big sur which
has a
incredible flora
uh and
he had a little app where he would it's
like what is this tree and then an app
where he would take pictures of it yes i
think you picture this yes is that what
it's called yes and he would be like
that is a uh northern new zealand uh
magnus
dragon optimus prime and i'd be like
dragon bush i won't be at coachella
[Applause]
we'll be at whitney's house
is an amazing app i actually it's like
ten dollars though you take a picture of
a flower or a plant and it tells you
what it is and it also when you take the
photo of the actual plant it can detect
any sort of disease or
like sort of definition of your vagina i
am i'm my dragon bush my dry dragon bush
they're gonna be like you miss paternal
love
water it twice a week but he did love
you he just showed it in act and his
behavior not verbally he showed it in
comedy that he showed it in jokes he
showed it in
making me laugh and being fun and moving
three blocks away from
the neighbor you know what i mean like
for me my whole thing is i get older i'm
like it's not about words it's all about
action because my thing is i've heard it
so much from people that really hurt me
and from people and and i love you is
confusing because i don't want to feel
like well we said i love you it's kind
of this like fake
marker right where you're supposed to
and it puts you like all these
expectations on it yes and and it also
puts unfair expectations on the person
that says like the guy's like don't say
that yet because i s we haven't we're
not
monogamous yet i don't i haven't made
your friends yet i don't know where your
ex is like
i don't want to be like we're in love
and then be disappointed by the action
ten times more than it needs to hurt
just because we say i love you now right
because we feel like we need to fill the
space with something and sometimes
sometimes i love you is a
used to manipulate you know like but i
love you and you're like okay how do i
argue with that right it's like but this
isn't like i've been waiting for this my
whole life i just i'm going to accept it
as love because i want the love i want
to feel it i don't want to hear it i
feel the same way yeah and it's like
that whole thing you know actions speak
speak louder than words and the other
thing and if your actions are
incongruous with what the person is
saying get the fuck out it's taking me
so long oh it takes so long to realize
that but also
anyone can say anything the way people
communicate is different and you also
have to take responsibility for how
you've received love how you identify
love and being able to identify other
people's love language what is yours
touch and
verbalization so yours is verbal
affirmations and physical contact it's
your love language yes mine is if you
can go to love language.com i'm just
burning your shoulders with your shirt
[Music]
keep bringing up the curling iron
because guess what auntie whitney is
going to be on qvc
schlepping curling out you better
burn and turn oh a curling iron yes uh
uh
burnt burnt
[Laughter]
the burnt barrel oh get there the crack
the crack the crackhead barrel
everybody we hope you had a great
episode and don't write elephants
okay you i was trying to go the line of
like roast roast your hair roast it yeah
no see now i'm annoyed i'm gonna try to
beat it i'm gonna get the whole rest of
this podcast i'm gonna try to beat that
joke hold on let me just put this down
so when you're talking about it
you're never going to address it yeah no
i'm no we are going to read this we're
going to go through all i mean i'm going
to read this list and we're going to go
through all of them but whatever we were
just saying was important well we were
talking about um the
oh so the love language i realized
you know verbalization and physical
touch are my jam and a lot of men that i
have been attracted to or who have been
attracted to me
their language is service yes a lot of
men's services a lot of men's service
and
and you have to the i think one of the
biggest and physical touch can be a
foreign service it sure can yeah servant
blue jobs
yes that's an access that's that is an
act of service
um
i honestly think that one of the things
that people can do to really save
themselves from a lot of
relationship
trauma is
try to hold back on projecting how you
want to be loved and start to recognize
how other people
love mm-hmm and i learned that recently
and i think you know losing
my parents are dead i don't know
your parents are dead losing people
you said something to me
i said you know my heart is broken and
you said just make sure it breaks open
i almost cried um
and
if you're gonna have your heart broken
make sure it breaks yeah and and so i
like honestly
that is something i like have thought
about and like keeping my heart open and
knowing how i express my heart and in
being able to recognize how other people
express their heart is a big thing where
people have issues in their
relationships and
it's not that
it's impossible to have communication
you just have to know when somebody is
communicating something to you and if
they speak a different language you
don't get to be xenophobic and be like i
don't get it you don't go to you know
another country and go speak english
right now you try to learn their
language exactly the same thing with
love it's like if someone's showing you
love in a way that is not the way you
show love because of whatever childhood
circumstances and your attachment style
you don't get to be like if you don't
give love the way i give love like you
suck and you're broken and you're a
psycho it's like no you're a narcissist
an emotional perfectionist right so and
that was me for so many years and here's
what i'm learning i mean i did go to an
attachment strategy
meditation course this whole thing to
try to change your attachment strategy
but to me my love language i feel like a
lot of people have been listening to
your podcast and creating therapy camps
for you to go to just you
people come up to me i went to this new
um horse equestrian
internal anal rape um
so i basically therapeutic
training camp dog fighting but it's one
people in one comedian
and it really gets you out of your ego i
went to this new bedazzling your soul
while somebody's holding your hair back
and your nipples
emotional love therapy camp and here's
what i learned yes yes yes it is will be
there it is it's a hashtag
and so
which we need to get more of in your
panties um we'll talk about that in a
second gwyneth how is this not on the
site
that is for just the listeners only uh
this is a horseshoe paper towel holder i
have right here that i have ordered
thrice
uh on nyquil every time
it's for paper towels
why isn't there fucking what did you
think it was
a seat for another guest that is that is
not a sybian that is a paper towel
holder
again again with the slurs
again with the front it is
look a little dangerous like it is
definitely very you're getting you have
tetanus put it down and so
we are the color of tetanus thank you
also no scurvy oh my god are you
bleeding i just poured um a pomegranate
juice on my boob and it looks like i'm
lactating god you're levitating blood
which you would if when you get pregnant
and it would be blue it would be blue
we'll be right back
we'll we're never coming back never
every final episode
we now take a break
from two women
grappling with imminent death to talk
about our favorite game our favorite
favorite
telephone game we play here operation no
that is our second favorite game
favorite game every time i look at one
of my friends anyone on this team
they're playing best fiends ben and i
went to vegas on the way back i'm
playing instead of playing truth or dare
with me
look what he was doing
what are you doing
[Music]
i thought you were on instagram or
texting
[Music]
play it so we can see
and i was topless that entire flight
barely looked at me which is why i
couldn't sit by her because they're
booed to another seat
look my body is my boobs are first class
my body's coach
look i get it i get it i wish you guys
were doing things around here but if you
want to play best fiends instead
honestly i get it and frankly it's fair
it's fair it i've played best fiends
it's the only time i've ever felt actual
joy so i mean playing it it becomes like
your mission in life your life goal to
win
every single level
give up that fruit stand dream you have
a mission now okay
download the five star rated puzzle game
best fiends free today on the app store
or on google play that's friends without
the r best fiends even if you don't have
best friends you can have best fiends
if y'all know anything about me it said
i like to sleep
we know you by now
i do like sleep is very important to me
not only do i like to sleep i also lie
down
sometimes i'll lie down
i'm not sleeping i just like to lie down
and regroup i'm just resting your body
i'm resting my body and my eyelids so
sometimes i'll i'll go in there i'll be
like i need a nap or i need to go lie
down they're two different things
you guys know me i'm if you look around
i'm laying somewhere somewhere i don't
know
i'm always sleeping we are basically
narcoleptic and i it's a miracle any of
us ever are on the same sleep cycle
there's about a three hour window a day
where we're all awake at the same time
so we better get through this you all
know that i'm obsessed with brooklyn and
products so take it take a look take a
look at what happens when i am in
brooklyn pajays
it's
a real sight to see
whitney get her she's got to get up we
have to get started come on mommy
oh cute pajamas look a little pocket i
know at least she's not naked like
usually i'm so soft mommy hello wake up
dude
daisy hello wake up mommy
oh my god hello
mommy
oh you know what my mom used to do oh
what
get up carter it's time for school
man she is out
trying to put tickle her
pull her hair
kick her kick her in the back
oh that was pretty good oh i know
wait a minute don't don't use that at
least kill her with the brook linen
sheets oh that's right okay emily i know
that you're trying to kill me it's
totally fine
as long as you bury me in brook linen
i don't want an embarrassing funeral
with some ratchet sheets that you get on
overstock.org
oh and you get all my dogs in the will
emily
[Laughter]
i don't have a big spoon personality but
i'll do it
harassment
harassment on every
level
we were jealous
yeah you look so cozy i mean i basically
have sleep apnea that is not sleep apnea
okay well it felt suffocating i felt
like i was being choked to death
and was never gonna get back from under
the water that was a dream okay well
okay the gas lighting has really hit the
next level this is murder at this point
i know that felt that that was an idea
they came up with as a way to try to
murder me
uh
as a bit
from pillows to sheets to towels to
loungewear to pajamas that are cute as a
button by the way and candles brook
linen can absolutely do no wrong they
make rest and relaxation a real dream
come true so go on get comfortable and
get it for less whoop okay do you
haven't slept you know what i haven't
slept in the last two hours right so now
i'm not an optimal version of my little
baby i know when i'm not wearing
brooklyn and sheets i'm just
awake yeah things are just a nightmare
away my skin is burning in any other uh
fabric brooklyn it makes rest and
relaxation a real dream come true no
night terrors here so go on get
comfortable and get it for less at
brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com and use
promo code whitney to get 20
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter promo code whitney for 20 off
with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's brooklyn.com promo code
whitney don't sleep on that deal
wake up also you can change your love
language and evolve as you get older so
for me what's hard how do you do it i i
to me i think you can evolve i'm so
sorry i don't think consciously
consciously because you're kind of
ingrained don't you think in a way it
depends so you can change a habit in 30
days it takes 28 days to make a new
neural pathway so it depends on what the
habit is so and also changing your
attachment strategy your attachment
strategy changes with every person
you're with based on their attachment
strategy right so if we're both
preoccupied
avoidant if we start dating if you end
up being if you're preoccupied more
preoccupied than i am i will become
avoidant i feel like you're letting me
know how we'll be able to have a
successful relationship mm-hmm i'm just
telling you what you need to do well
you're learning better to live here if i
squint like this you look like annie
really yeah it's weird i think the weed
drink might kick in a little okay yeah
yeah i'm gonna call adam divine and tell
him a little bit he needs to stop
sending me these weed drinks these are
delicious though but just
driving she is trying i'll take it i'll
take it she's she's ovulating she's in
the ovulation mode um so if you cannot
necessarily change your you can
consciously change your attachment
strategy but it's 50 so every
relationship is 50 50. so the other
person is triggers you recreates your
childhood circumstances is a you know
lethal combination of the negative
qualities of your primary caretakers
your mom and your dad and kicks up all
this adrenaline and cortisol in which
case when you are are you blacking out
i'm so sorry no i
[Music]
i wish
pat wishes still not convinced this
isn't the a.i what do you mean this is a
why does everyone think what is your
world string ascension together
my robot it
where is that bitch by the way because i
think i think whitney's on vacation and
i'm here with the fucking robot someone
tweeted me the other day uh
i've never seen the lady from the
progressive commercials in whitney in
the same room just saying
that's funny that's really funny so good
i was like i hate how funny that is
she had her uh body shot in half for a
movie
and her face is currently getting a
little bit of an update because she um i
made her two years ago and she already
looks younger than me and i i i won't
she had a jacker up yeah that bitch
needs some curls good for you yeah so
she does and then also we got her
eyebrows uh and they were they basically
just took hair from a wig and put it on
her face and it just looks like little
hitler mustaches so we are going back to
square one
as i said in my last special the reason
that robots are not going to look
necessarily realistic or be able to read
faces well is because robots are
building robots it's a little bunch of
nerds that have never been with a woman
so like so do you think eyebrows are
just long hair and some people do have
these very protrusive eyebrows that come
out but there's like six people in the
world who have that like you've got to
figure out once it drafted the
constitution yes
yes i don't and he'll wear wigs and it
literally it is they just took hair from
a wig and just put it over her eyes like
a straight line that's insane i was like
that is how little you guys just flew
out of my mouth
that was not out of your mouth i know
exactly where that was out of we all
know where
we all know where that fly came from and
jordan peel make a movie about that get
out
get out
jeff goldblum we have a
great reference did they make two or
three can we both agree again add side
note podcast episode that jeff goldblum
is
a fox jeff goldblum is so
funny and talented and cunning and
self-deprecating
here's my jazzy it's very hard to
separate
if someone is famous
and if i just saw that person on the
street and they hadn't been in a bunch
of my favorite movies would i be like
i don't know that's hard to do i don't
know i just think he's he's in his in
the ign enigmatic his lips are his lips
his lips know the assignment
god don't you think that's a great
sentence
jeff goldblum's lips know the inside
just like even take his name out and a
lot of girls that you have to ask
yourself do you does your man does this
lips do they do they know they don't
really know the assignment
because if they don't it's just such a
waste it's a waste of time
so
jeff goldblum is so
hot to me but i can't tell if it's like
he's so freaking talented he's so
talented he's so talented and so
understated and weird but i conflate
when someone is talented and i'm in awe
of them i really that is my love
addiction so who's your who's your
number one we're in the sexiest person
yeah who's like brad pitt
and probably counter reeves are my guys
and zoe kravitz that's my crew right
we're right so
remember todd barry had this joke we
were gonna stop right there okay
sex my number one hall pass no but todd
i think todd berry used to do this joke
that was so um was such a slow burn and
he would talk to the audience and go
like oh my god did you hear that
oh no was that another fly no my dry
vagina just got wet the mention of todd
berry continue
so he used to do this joke where he
would say
so
he would i i'm obviously going to
butcher it youtube it he would say so um
to the audience
so how many people women here love brad
pitt i'm like going crazy and then he
goes so if you had to choose between
between having sex with me and brad pitt
who would you choose
like so brad pitt
um
with leprosy
or me they're like
and he just keeps going to these extreme
scenarios
and there's no ostensible joke on the
horizon and then i was like
he just goes all right well i just have
news for you brad pitt would never fuck
any of you
it was it's just so perfectly done and
he's like but i will so what are we
doing like
it was just such a perfect
take about how we sit around and really
chris evans is disgusting i would always
be with brad pitt none of them are
interested so are you telling me brad
pitt would never fuck me
i don't you know what's really weird i
don't know that much about him i feel
like brad pitt almost is more beloved by
men at this point than women i think he
is he's gotten definitely a feminine
situation that moment where he
tips his cowboy hat and the rain water
falls out at julia armond and legends of
the fall
is truly what i go to if i can't have an
orgasm i mean that's where everyone
every woman they tip
their pelvis down and rain water comes
out in there that's it that's just what
happened are you dating someone
kind of okay hypothetically allegedly
okay
totally attracted
vagina dries up
now i have it doesn't dry up it just
doesn't get super wet as soon as you
get in the back of the torus
now imagine trying to imagine i want to
give you a scenario does he have a pt
cruiser no no no does he wear true
religion jeans no no none of that
does he get botox no
he's a he's a dirty dirty man does he
call his mom mommy no he's even call her
and that's why i love him
okay does he have a job
yes okay okay um is it a real one or a
hobby a real one okay
make some money okay um
you know what you say how dry does it
get
imagine you look like you're from
whoville
says the bitch with the with the fucking
crunchy burnt hair dude i am with this
this is the actual hairstyle the grinch
wore yeah you look like the daughter
the little girl i look like javier
bardem and sky fall you look you really
do look amazing
i know women like say that by the way
we've never looked better neither of us
we've really i know
i this was a vitamin this whole thing
about getting older
has been a total plot twist for me oh my
god the fact that i dreaded it and i
feel like i've never looked better is so
weird to me yo i look at photos of me
from 15
haggar
where are you she's lost why is she
bloated she's lost why are there dried
mascara teeth under her face bleeding is
there cheese on her waterline she
squeezed all those zits that didn't
exist yeah are those zits or did she
face plant into the goddamn concrete
she's hemorrhaging from the face is that
a stigmata is it 22 or crack
why isn't that lip liner anywhere in the
same zip code as her lips did she line
her lips with the eyebrow and line her
eyebrows with her lip liner are those
tendrils is that a dick in her ear
no
it's a
piercing that she did
at claire's with a guy
named tristan
[Laughter]
who she met
at the ed hardy store
he worked at claire
it is like it's such a crazy thing i
always think of um
uh what's that beautiful uh actresses i
did it italian i did it again
are you wiping yourself with a thong no
i'm this is my bra i'm wiping off my
chin pomegranate it looks like the song
you wear on the fourth day of your
period
[Laughter]
so you get to a fourth day oh girl
actually i don't really get to a fourth
day appropriation appropriation tricky
tricky tricky tricky tricky tricky
you're too tan for that it's tricky i'm
just saying this could go very justin
trudeau very fast tristan trudeau
[Laughter]
is this a podcast or two mental
breakdown we're not recording this
are you insane i'm just trying to keep
our friendship going
i've had a couple people you didn't ask
i asked you
and uh a lot of people asked to be on
and i have this i have this um
uh
fantasy that i just have a bunch of
people on and it's just not really about
i went around and i am enjoying it yeah
i really wouldn't mind but my definitely
have my lawyers call you if this video
okay your lawyers plural how many
lawyers do you have what company
was the most
fear-filled throw you will never get to
be in coyote ugly and your perfect
casting and you're not going to be able
to get the job because you can't commit
to throwing again
were you worried there was more left
what was your concern swallow whatever
can you imagine if i was like hey
that was a funny bit but seriously you
need to give me six grand for the fact
that was pathetic dude i want to be able
to make fun of what you did but there
aren't empty enough cans
i honestly seriously almost pissed
myself just there this is what you did
you were like
are you the bit was so clear huh
the bit was right there like
he placed it down
[Laughter]
that by the way i'm kind of like that
when i try to do sexy things like in
lingerie oh my god i'll be like didn't
oh don't touch it
don't touch it
yeah so that's what's happening wait you
were talking about how you invited me i
didn't bite myself and a lot of people
invite themselves oh yeah and that i
fantasize about just doing a day where i
just record podcasts that never air so
people think you should and then you
should hear it but then air it in a
place where they don't get to see
because dubai where you're from with
that on your head no you went there
you've got to take this off this is
my space
is it
yes okay
and you're claiming it
pat laughed at it so it must
you are good at coming in and claiming
your space thank you i appreciate that
and you're trying to tear it down i
thought you were a pro woman
for women
[Music]
a pro-woman for women
that's your
i'm not going to say what i was going to
say you're covered in blood okay
no then i would be blue
so what is going on here's what i'll say
i'll take this off the dry vagina thing
i know this is like feels like a gross
conversation but i think it's important
it is important because it is their job
oh yeah to get it wet it's not your job
okay can i say their job
i put on the bra
i put on the rouge
i put on the eye sha i put on the
shimmer it's a it's a
dual effort
you know it's like
we're not just we you can't just go like
this there has to be
you know evolution to everything that's
going on sexually how fast is this going
down how big of a rush are you in
exactly i think it just needs to be
slowed down yeah i think i just need to
grease up you need to marinate i need a
marinade you just marinate a bit i
really why is he in such a rush
he's very busy is he yeah he's a very
busy i mean it's he's busy he's got like
a job
you know i mean he's got he has to go
other places and
you know i'm doing the thing where women
like validate no i just think we get
excited and we just go right into it but
that's okay also okay i don't like
it to be so slippery that you can't feel
anything yeah because then there's no
choice is that a baby like what right
like if a car gets stuck in the mud you
need a little bit of traction and get
the fuck out of the mud it can't be all
you know whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's a whole wave what do you mean we
got to put this down a little my hair
yeah what i do i just dropped it okay
they're oh my jarring i am thank you
you know what i love when girls tell
other girls like you gotta oh that looks
crazy bitch fix me i love it so much i
do it to strangers i'm like bitch you
got a tag
and some shit when someone when someone
i don't know it's like you have
something in your teeth i'm like you're
my bitch for life yes let a bitch know
and like this whole we can handle it we
can handle it i'm a grown-ass yeah what
are you putting on putting on lip gloss
you don't need it this is uh joan
osborne i'm sorry sharon osbourne what
if god where's whatever
oh my god can i tell you that's an
embarrassing thing that happened to me
one time huh i did you know doug benson
i did getting doug with hi
with a melissa etheridge
and she was promoting
her her her pot farm she's like
yesterday
cannabis farm yeah yes and i told her
pepperidge farms etheridge farms like
pep bridge farms yes yes that is the
she's like banking on that misspelling
google yes exactly misspelling pepperage
farm stoners are like i need a cookie
willow company oh shit
and so i was stoned with her and i said
you should name one of your strains come
to my window
and she went she looked at me and went
nope
on tv in front of everyone i was like
okay okay okay
i resign as creative director i'm sorry
i thought it was created i think we're
just saying come to my window as like a
topical cbd lube oh that would be good
come
in my window hold on let's name melissa
etheridge's cannabis strains we should
we should come come frank sorry i'm oh
my god that's my password and i'm
writing it down and i said it out loud
everyone's gonna tap in um there are so
many horse rings on your hands yes many
rings of horses yes
i have this is actually pretty a light
day i have two horse rings on right now
one is on my ring finger because i got
bloated and it didn't fit on my analogy
okay wait back wrapping up one let's
button one thing okay
the equestrian therapy the videos you'd
post
do horses really react to your energy
and is indicative of what the output is
for you yes correct it's such a
complicated
thing and i'm going to try to be
eloquent and i'm already bored the
problem
[Laughter]
so am i
i want to know you i really want to know
because i cry
no i i do feel like i should answer this
in a clear way it's just going to take a
second
you just took a shot of tequila yeah i
thought there was we have shot cups
little mini shot cups so you want to do
shots shots cortisone shots you don't
want to do your blood drink and
hopefully we need a b12 shot shots
yeah we do everybody you're putting in
pomegranate juice into your drink just a
little bit
it's a lot of sugar that's not good for
you like the way i do i'm looking at
melissa are you checking your emails no
do we stop recording no i'm looking at
melissa etheridge songs okay yes yes all
right all right and there's less than i
recall really yeah
bring me some come to my window i'm the
only one like the way i do is a very
sexy only blunt i'm the only blunt yeah
yep okay the way like the way i do like
the way
i do be
boom
we'll we'll dance we'll go with it is
that a grandparent doobie is for the
dads oh uh okay the weed the marijuana
for the the jazz cabbage i want to come
over
i
wanna
blacked out
i think i wanna come over you forget my
childhood i it could just be like a
sexual song that we'll make
i want to come over to you what's up
i want to
i want to come over hold on i don't
remember that i don't remember this can
i play
i did you get in trouble
you went to melissa etheridge's wedding
uh-huh
did the weed drink just kick in
i actually did
i actually did go to her wedding her
wife was uh i've worked with a lot she's
brilliant her name is linda wallin i'm
at wallin mallam with an m mom my mom
mama that the ouija drink did you just
kidding me
don't have to have wet pussy because my
tongue is 10
times the size of my mouth
you know what's weird i am doing
podcasts after five o'clock now because
i have construction on my house it is a
known fact check reddit check
oh you're right
your brain is done at night i stutter a
lot i do too my tongue is like so you
know how your like feet get swollen at
the end of the night i can't i don't
have that that's gross i don't know what
that is but
you are a wheelchair pregnant you're a
wee lass do you know your um
what is that you're like a like your
frame is very small and tight
you know what you are you're the body
type
i'll i'm about to hit you if you you'd
be a top you
hmm you'd be a top
for me you wouldn't do me from behind oh
baby you want to peg me no no no i nap
nap time for mama okay yeah yeah
okay we don't do on top anymore okay we
have uh basketball relations generally
from behind yay i we're both side by
side we're side by side
high fives crying watching virginia
how can a river be virgin uh ask brad
pitt
a river ran through it
i've not seen virgin river people love
it you'll love it why
it's just it's so good
it's so good it's what we need
why give me a give me something martin
henderson that's it don't know who that
is yep and alexandra the main actress
which is terrible of me not to know her
name but i'm aware what's it about give
me one something um
uh him and this hawkeye yeah this hot
guy he's in the woods doing woodsy
things yeah but really
oh my god
they're listening why is jeff goldblum
telling me where to live i don't know
but why did jeff goldblum you know show
up 10 minutes after we talked about him
you know what they really missed out on
a great jurassic park reference here
where for apartments.com they should go
life will find a way in your new
apartment
[Music]
remember that jeff goldblum moment
oh my god it's like the whole
theme of jurassic park
apartments.com brand new apartments
where none of the appliances are archaic
and they won't come to life and eat you
alive jurassic park 17 coming out this
fall with chris pratt and 17 000 cgi
dinosaurs this is i'm obsessed with how
okay we have to look up his net worth
jeff goldwater um 17 million
hmm it's gonna be that commercial it's a
weird number but i feel strong i feel
strong about who we got hold on let's
see we got that that 40 million
well here's what i'll say he's broke his
shirts are expensive
you
actually might be right because i think
celebrity net worth is based on what
they earn
minus taxes and minus agents so you
might be let's do our exactly right do
mine okay
wait do bread pit first wait bro
just to see like how much i'm gonna have
to bring here's the thing here's what
i'll say brad pitt it does a lot of
watch ads in china that you've never
done in tokyo oh you go to china or you
go to tokyo and you're seeing george
clooney for like
you know twix you're like huh like they
do a lot of undercover um ad campaigns
that they they don't show in america
it's like bill murray's character from
lost and translated that's exactly right
so which is a great great like brad
pitt's the face of watches hemorrhoid
creams all kinds of stuff
200 mil
202 mil does he have a lifestyle brand
does he have a yeah it's my pussy hole
check it put it in he did he pretended
like keith it's in his pocket that's why
it's dry
so why
okay hold on does he have a brand does
he have a licker like george yeah he's
gonna lick me
does he lick her yes i don't think
bradley
i don't know if brad pitt has to do that
okay brad pitt celebrity net worth ready
go
202 mill 300 million
so that probably means 150 million yes
so i was close okay jesse may yeah this
is funny by the way this should just be
a dating app at this point celebrity
network it should yeah that's great
uh you don't know how to spell money no
i do no that's right right yeah we'll go
with that p-a-l-o-u-s-e-e-l
uso uso
it means
palace hair and uso is many many hairs
you want to see my bung
i was going to say on the crevice
net worth
i mean mtv is kind of it's big brutal
they're like did you mean
it's big money
oh my god jessie made paluso family wow
we're going in deep mine's not even yeah
we buried that shit where is it i read
it what do you mean i buried a sicilian
mafia yeah jessie mappaloosa oh cutie
pie cutie american comedian well known
television personality we're shooting
the intro right now uh she is known for
working the first two seasons of mtv
show girl coach she's performed in
stand-up comedies for more than a decade
on average she appeared on more than 25
television shows some of her shows
include mtv's girl code nbc's last call
with carson daly my first writing job
funny or die lights out with david spade
she also hosted a show called shark
tongue
you still do that right yeah i do i
don't know why they thought it was done
she attracted half a million followers
on social media platforms including
facebook twitter instagram and megan's
law jessie
jesse may palooza was born september
16th i'm the fourth watch the year watch
the year
by the way same year you know
exact year can i tell you something i
can tell you something i'm too excited
at the same time at the same time
you shut your whore mouth i am your boss
are you i am two weeks older than you
now that i know that i'm never to let
you talk to me like that again bitch the
last time i was like in your presence
was on your birthday and you got me all
fucking tattooed and pierced
they look so good we got it here and it
wasn't a birthday party it was a goddamn
seance and you were collecting souls it
was an initiation i'm tagged i had my
girlfriends come over and got them
piercings let me see is it the one that
they look they look so good i all of
them i had to get my ben
damn it another time i screwed up a joke
did you get my venmo invoice
well didn't get the joke
or the invoice
no but it looks so good do you have
trouble sleeping when you pierce in
cartilage trouble sleeping in general it
hurts for
it just healed either way you go you
have to put salt water spray on it at
all it takes a year but what i was going
to say is i've always felt this need to
lie about my age not recently
um
but you were one of the people who i
felt encouraged to just be honest about
how old i am because and even like i
wanted to tack on like 10 years just
like i'm fucking 48. yeah so people can
be like you look amazing what are you
doing well that's the thing everybody
tells me i have such amazing skin and
they're like you're my skin is amazing
i'm like but do you think i'm 62.
you're like i don't give a fuck do i
have a medicine for 62. you're four
thirty eight-year-olds okay quick quick
button give it sophia loren this is
about ageism i can't stand
ageism it's one of my biggest pet peeves
like oh for your age you look good for
this women this age oh i can't wear this
i'm too old it makes me look too young
but i can't it's so scary
so silly because of this one thing that
i always think about sofia wren she was
interviewed when she was like in her
late 60s they said what's one of your
biggest regrets she said and jessie may
saw this in person and she is lying
about her age it was actually in person
it wasn't an interview it was a it was
pep peers it was a salon it was being at
the coliseum um a very native american
script it was a symposium at the lions
club yes it was being spoken in a native
tongue of an indigenous tribe that has
now since been destroyed by models
in malibu um
it is now a ralph lauren campaign it is
now the poster for um american eagles
sophia lauren is that a um is it on
youtube
it might be on youtube she talks about
you know her biggest regret
not loving herself she's like you know i
look back at when i was in my 30s and
taking myself apart about my thighs and
all this and i realized
every moment in my life was my greatest
moment in life and the moments where i
picked myself apart i just was taking
away my magic
and here i am in my late 60s wishing i
had the body that i hated when i was in
my 30s
and so like that for me
for women you just have to really
embrace where you're at and be like yeah
i'm fucking 38.
or anything where it's like i used to
this is so embarrassing when i was in uh
working the writer's room on a tv show i
was so afraid of getting wrinkles i'm
like 28 at this point because i also
grew up with a lot of ubiquitous
messaging about
i i need to lose five pounds i need to
lose eight pounds i need the subtleness
of it i have family members that can
just put full makeup on with no mirror
in public all the time i mean it was
always a debutante show a beat face at
all times southern and it was always you
look gorgeous i need to lose five pounds
it was a lot of that so i just learned
an early age that no matter how pretty
you are there's always room to improve
nothing's ever good enough you can
always be thinner or shinier have
thicker hair or we are two of the
shiniest bitches in the industry we are
per opalescent
what's that
a clean and clear oil blots bitch
what where did you what is that i mean
this stops up the oil are you still
using like zema
nah
where did you what gas station in new
mexico did you get this at your dead
dad's
[Music]
i know when we first met oh i think it
was a lot factory corner no i was i i
was looking for a prostitute and you
were standing right there no
and you took paypal no this is i'm going
to really put myself out you're going to
blow something embarrassing i love it
that's what we do here um i used to date
chris angelo start rolling the
embarrassing part
i love chris franchola
your dad didn't do that bad of a job if
you did chris rancho great
um and i went to go see him when you
guys were on a tour with chelsea
the uh comedians of chelsea lately
at the club nokia
is that was i wearing a brown shirt yes
and you know what i told you
this is really because
when i say this you're gonna have enough
you're gonna have a reaction was this
before after i met you on the corner
this is way before okay so i i don't
remember i was
just getting into comedy
debatable
i'm 67.
hazelfield run i don't know if you're
still alive but my collagen is um
i said to you
it was backstage and i go
you know you're really funny
i think you're really funny for a
girl don't write elephants
do you
remember saying that i don't remember
hearing i remember saying it and i said
disassociated i remember your face you
were like
i had a stroke yeah you gave me bell's
palsy
i was like i was so young and dumb and
just didn't know anything by the way
honestly experience true
very true very true
i would like to redact
the funny part
you're pretty for a girl
so pretty for a comic
can i tell you
i've said such dumb that's like your i
carried a watermelon moment from dirty
dancing chris
after that
after i said that to you and we had it
was just awkward
and we walked away was it i don't know
it remembered for a second you you
handled it you were like oh okay hey
thanks yeah yeah yeah you're like fuck
off like you know your eyes are like
fuck off i did not do that no no you
didn't say it but
now knowing i don't i don't think i was
i think for me at that time that must
have been 12 years you were just like
whatever i think i was so
disassociated like when i would meet
another community a person i was so
focused on trying to impress
or anticipate their needs or try to like
shape shift to figure out what they
wanted from me that i i truly
i'm going to do one better yeah
i wasn't listening to you yeah that's
exactly what it was i was so busy
probably trying to get your approval or
figure out that i didn't even hear the
insult that's what i felt it didn't even
land but franzola did
oh and we walked a few feet he goes what
the fuck buddy he's like
of all the things he's like everyone
here chelsea lately say she's not funny
just onto her face are you crazy he's
such a class act he was like of all the
things you could say to a female comic
that's the one thing you never say to a
female comic just tell them they're
fucking funny you don't need to quantify
their sexuality or their identification
right pc police and then he's he just
engulfed himself in flames because he's
a devil reincarnate but you know what
i'll say everyone that has been mean to
me i don't know if i'm just like post
micro dose and ketamine or just in the
pandemic losing a parent like you get
into this nihilistic space okay oh yeah
my parents did both
fucking to win the most sad stop trying
to steal it
biggest traumatized people you know just
know i am first place gold winner you're
silver you're pretty sad for a
half orphan
it's my equivalent orphan
[Laughter]
new show on netflix is fall
nope it's on ciso
and so
it's weird because i'm at this place
where and when people like negative
comments are like so bad and they hurt
my feelings and the internet hurts my
feelings and all these and comments my
dude i got so much abuse
in comedy or stuff and i'm so grateful
for it i know that's crazy i don't know
if this is a stockholm syndrome thing
but everything that i think my parents
failed and doing or failed and providing
i look at people that have had all of
their needs met their emotional needs
met their physical needs met their
monetary needs their nutritional needs
matt everything you are useless you have
no skills you have no adaptability when
i am in a situation with a person that
had a quote-unquote good childhood they
are so useless and they're also they're
uh miserable they're miserable but they
don't understand what a trauma really is
they're a liability they're truly
reliable they don't anticipate uh
anything ever danger at all times not
even a sandwich because they always had
a sandwich they don't even
it's there's always they're like i'm
hungry what do we do it's like
how do you not have a plan you never
starve i'm sorry you know you have a
protein bar in your purse my mom gave me
vanilla sausages from my kids and
you don't know how to open a
spam can with your teeth you didn't come
home from school no one was home for
four hours i am so sorry you can't sleep
in a refrigerator you didn't like have
your mom go for four jobs after the you
got home from what's your plan your dad
didn't remarry four times
you didn't have to poison your mom's new
boyfriend you can't handle craft
mac and cheese
side note i just bought a new vibrator i
often never used a vibrator off of
instagram is it made by women for women
okay what's more drawing that you've
never used a vibrator i got mine off a
fucking instagram it's pretty equally um
despicable you've never used it i've
never used a vibrator
i've had guys like use them because
they're like i don't know need to have a
do you just not need surgeon fantasy
i've just never
i i'm not a prop comic
well i guess i'm gonna change my pussy's
name to gallagher
i don't have a suitcase full of items i
got one but what is that how do you what
do you i grew up without money what are
you okay the queen of versailles it was
20 you put 20 bucks into having an
orgasm well the corner of this table
just gave me a hard nipple that is not
thrifty
you have one harder the other one not so
it's like you're winking oh she looks
like she's winking at me i've never used
looking her in the face i've never used
yeah a sex toy what i don't get how to
use them i don't know how
never i think i've also never used
garage band not a butt plug
guys are into that okay so that's a sex
guy into it it was his idea and i didn't
understand what was in all fairness i
didn't understand what was happening but
he was very excited and i wanted to move
past okay so i'm gonna now use the
excuse i didn't understand what's
happening to say that i didn't do things
smart
i say i was i'm a virgin do you know how
many
things i've gotten to pass for by saying
i was in a coveted fog
because i was oh yeah you were a good
two months and then i stretched it for
like another two minutes as you should i
was like covet fog yeah no you need the
covered fog is still here by the way
it's still here and it's wrapped around
it it's real curling iron
i am going to
sodomize you with that girly iron see
now that would be a bunch of sex toys
where do you draw the line what's the
one that you bought on instagram um it's
one that goes in
and then it has so it's what's it called
the
uh purple the yeast infection creator
it's a
uti
uh assistant the loneliness the joy luck
lonely club the cougar
the cougar john cougar melon crotch it's
the purple okay
the eggplant no purple vibrator
instagram
this is going to fuck up my outfit no it
won't it's really going to improve it
why purple
makes me think of birdie mac that's the
color that's racist
it's not racist we tried the amazon vibe
wait this one
the internet is obsessed with okay
the vibrator just based off the reviews
i'll know the shape i'll know the shape
the dozens of women saying they died
after using this and one woman said she
was seeing colors
that's a one
i don't understand where it is
suction and g-spot vibrator oh god
there's not a dog in it oh no that is
not legal why is there a shirt okay
what was that dual ended suction and
g-spot vibrato okay so you see the
little scoop sorry we couldn't find that
page why do they keep showing all the
dogs i know i don't want to be looking
at a dog when i'm thinking about sex
toys thanks so much so you see the
little you sounded like i don't
understand where any of this goes he
sounded like fucking what's his name
baron cohen oh did i which character
borat oh god thank you so much okay so i
don't understand what this is okay so
you see the long you see the part that
looks like a mouth on the top
it's not a mouth
that doesn't look like a mouth that
looks like your mouth maybe mouths are
just an idea that's a mouth
time is just a concept it's a social
construction exactly that is the mouth
of uh an octopus that is like that is a
click cap and you put that right over
your clit i don't
think mine would fit but okay well then
you know you might need to do some
crunches i'm learning that i have a jojo
you might need to do something i need to
do some key goals and i need some people
i need to do
we might need like maybe
you might need a raisin that you might
yeah i don't know i've had enough no i
put her out in the sun
we need to dry your clit out yeah yeah
yeah maybe put a pour minimizer on it a
biore strip just skip a couple days of
hydration mm-hmm
like the bodybuilders you're going to
like i like it
maybe tighter thongs tighter thongs
so the the the part with the mouth
goes a top
on the outside of your body
the part that's uh
shaped like by the way what we're
looking at looks like this microphone by
the way it looks exactly like in hot
pink
so there's a part that goes inside and
there's a part that stays out it's like
hey what's up
so
the part that goes inside is ribbed and
it activates your g-spot which is
there's something wrong with my anatomy
i don't understand how that would fit
you think that but if you breathe out
and just shove it fast it goes in
breathe fast and shove it in well i mean
you can scooch it in gently but you said
shove well i have a tight entrance
who told you that
you're
[Laughter]
jesus dead
my dad's ashes
he's not really saying a lot if a
skeleton thinks your pussy's tight i
mean it's like i just pictured bill
murray from scrooge
but i i truly is this like does using
this make you not text that toxic guy
back like it's very it's a different
type of orgasm because
it's hard
anatomically to as a woman for me my
arms and the way i'm shaped to activate
my g-spot and
my clit at the same time it's a weird
positioning so this gives you that
and it's just a different sensation the
speed at which you pleasure yourself is
different the
um so you're lying down yeah you're
lying down or you could be in the shower
[Music]
be in your backyard while your neighbors
are telling you about their day why
shower because that do you have to put
in the dishwasher
these just feel like a chore to me i'm
not rich i don't have a dishwasher i
know there's like four people down there
that are just doing things in your
kitchen i'm not taking on any new
chargeable devices this i i understand
that no more chargers
no more usb cords i don't know what they
can go to
no more i have no more i'm out of holes
for charters i make capacity
well we could well we've written your
pro your dating profile
for i'm out of holes i'm all out of
holes farmers only.com look for my
profile i'm just a capacity
so this you do have to charge
there's no holes left the suction
technique in the it's honestly the
cheapest it's the best for your value
and they don't sponsor me i just got
them off of a whim
because it was like an
instagram thing and i was like i'll try
what this was suggested to you it just
popped up
and i popped it which means yeah but it
means that you
something's going on that they marketed
this to you yeah my drive vagina they
probably heard me talking about it yes
the way jeff goldblum just came up
what if jeff goldblum came up from dry
vagina what because he that might i mean
we said his name do you think why are
you saying that jeff goldblum is secure
to my dry vagina
we don't have a lot of time left well i
don't i'm not a home wrecker
no is he married we asked to a very
lovely woman oh and they have beautiful
children the circus a lay person yeah
she's she's beautiful
god he has a stud huh used i mean look
at her yeah look they might match
it's too far for me
it's cute though it's come on yeah they
look like they're an idiot look at their
beautiful baby i love the way he dresses
actually it's pretty gangster look at
their kids i know he dresses
too stud have you seen um uh what's the
movie that he did i love so much with
amanda pete igbe goes down i haven't
seen that oh it's such a great movie i
know i'm after he's he's a babe are you
kidding me oh
that's not my favorite picture that is
adorable i think the next generation of
women kind of don't who's this
generation's jeff goldblum now let's get
relevant and then we have to go okay
this generation's jeff goldblum so he's
gonna have to be younger but also like
he's era
i don't feel like michael sarah is this
like quick and
who's the guy that was the star of
facebook the facebook movie
oh jesse eisenberg oh yeah maybe it's
him like like hot
nerdy energy yeah like the accidental
sex symbol of the movie yeah he was
definitely accident like the underdog
jessie
eisenberg yes that's what i just said at
him i met him what did i say
in court
who did i say
michael sarah so michael sarah's
different yeah jesse eisenberg it's time
to ride that's him it's time to wrap up
well you've filled me of tequila how
many tequila shots have you had i this
is all i've had
that's what someone that has had more
says and i also had a weed drink and i
also had a rose okay and you force
fisted me you're you know what you're
dirty rotten curling iron you know you
are you're that girl at the club where
the guy's trying to get her leave and
she's like no
not leaving says the girl with blood all
over her shirt okay look
more the reason to stay the forensic
team is gonna need to come and take a
sample we're staying
i want mariska hargitay
to not have to track me down
girls who bleed together
leave together
are you on birth control
we started the conversation with this
okay and now i feel like this is a
political stance
does hope and tequila count
so on nothing
at 38 it kind of does
right honestly i mean at 38 it might
with this dry vagina could i get
pregnant i don't think it's that dry i
don't think that's right i think y'all
are just in a rush and it's unnecessary
i mean it's too um
it's too rushed it's too rush and that's
why i need brad pitt to run a river
through it no
you'll make your own river
this is definitely our
weirdest podcast episode that's because
of you
that's like the eighth lap
tv by the way this might be the most
i've ever seen pat that's really cool i
don't think i've ever seen him last i'm
always trying to get the person who has
to do the thing all the time with the
people who are always here and the
skippy and the scoopy and all that he's
pissed because everything that's making
him laugh he knows i'm gonna be like cut
it don't you everybody's gonna cut it
he's like i'm just trying to enjoy it
don't you emily emily emily's over there
making fucking notes look at this
picture emily come here right now look
at this picture of jeff goldblum come
here oh
so in love with her hold on come on
camera and look what he's wearing
stripes
[Laughter]
and her name's emily
oh my god
you might be his real soulmate
emily only wears stripes she likes to
just 62 how old is she i need to know
she's 31. she looks like she's
30 years younger now
good for her who cares about age fuck
age
he should be more comfortable with me he
looks like such a lover isn't that so
unfair how hot he's getting and how ugly
i'm getting society no that's not true
it's society uh the same person that
called me a horse yesterday called her
cartoon but i think that's a compliment
it means you look young cartoons don't
have wrinkles someone called you a
cartoon uh-huh to her face within the
first 30 seconds of meeting her you have
beautiful eyes wow i do feel like you
and jeff goldblum belong together
because you both like to dress like
mimes from broadway plays oh i thought
you meant me i got really excited
no
do you want to sign off jesse i have to
physically remove myself where are you
going
it's never going to end where are you
going don't write elephants don't write
elephants one last thing for the people
one last thing whitney
did she leave
[Music]
we're wrapped
foreign
[Music]
you